Hey guys, my name's Miles.
大家好，我叫迈尔斯。
I'm from Newton, Massachusetts.
我来自马萨诸塞州牛顿市。
I'm 27, and I have a lot to say, but I, like many other people, began watching the show when I was in middle school or high school, and particularly through Ted's character, but the whole show in general means a profound deal to me as I have battled in the passing to battle with the complexities of love and growing up, and I very much identify with Ted in his sort of naive, child-like, wondrous but also, I think, quite hopeful and passionate and resilient approach to romantic love and friendship love and family love and all of these things.
我今年27岁，我有太多话想说，但我和许多其他人一样，在初中或高中时就开始看这部剧了，特别是通过泰德这个角色，但整部剧对我的意义深远，因为我过去一直在与爱情和成长的复杂性作斗争，我在很大程度上对泰德产生了共鸣——他那种天真、孩子气、充满惊叹，但同时我也认为，他对浪漫爱情、友情、亲情以及所有这些事情有着相当充满希望、热情和韧性的态度。
So thank you for making sure I keep believing in those things.
所以感谢你们确保我继续相信这些事情。
I do want to say though that the show above all is so great because it is so true to sincerity and we live in a hyper ironic world right now where nobody wants to take each other seriously or be vulnerable out of fear of being made fun of or or some sort of un-nuanced, just hateful attack, and I think sincerity is scarce, but all the more important, which makes Jaime your mother all more important of a show.
不过我想说的是，这部剧最伟大的地方在于它对真诚无比忠诚，我们现在生活在一个过度讽刺的世界里，没有人愿意认真对待彼此，或者出于害怕被嘲笑或受到某种缺乏细微差别、纯粹充满仇恨的攻击而展现脆弱，我认为真诚很稀缺，但却更加重要，这也让《老爸老妈浪漫史》这部剧显得格外重要。
Thank you guys so, so much for this, and changing my life.
非常非常感谢你们带给我这一切，并改变了我的生活。
And Josh, I love liberal arts.
还有乔什，我爱《自由恋爱》。
It's one of my favorite movies ever, and I just want you to know that my heart is gooey because of you, if you know, you know, thank you.
这是我最喜欢的电影之一，我只是想让你知道，因为你，我的心变得软绵绵的，懂的都懂，谢谢你。
Bye-bye.
再见。
Hello, I'll be soon in New York City when I see you.
你好，我很快就会去纽约市看你们。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我把一切都告诉你，纽约市。
Well, hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
好的，大家好，欢迎收看另一期的《我们是如何创造老爸老妈浪漫史的》。
I'm Josh Radner, I am here with my good friend and former professional colleague, but forever friend, Craig Thomas, hi, Craig.
我是乔什·拉德纳，我和我的好朋友、前职业同仁但永远的朋友克雷格·托马斯在一起，嗨，克雷格。
Hey, Jess, we're still technically professional colleagues because we're doing this show.
嘿，杰西，从严格意义上讲我们还是职业同仁，因为我们在做这个节目。
Oh, yeah, we are professional colleagues.
哦，对，我们是职业同仁。
This is a professional.
这是一个职业。
So today we'll be discussing the Josh Rander 2012 film, Liberal Arts, I believe.
所以今天我们将讨论乔什·拉德纳2012年的电影《自由恋爱》，我想是的。
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you so much for that, audio.
非常感谢这段音频。
How nice is that to hear?
听到这个有多好？
That was fantastic.
这太棒了。
And yes, Alison Janney says to my character, put some armor around that gooey little heart of yours.
是的，艾莉森·珍妮对我的角色说，给你那颗软绵绵的心穿上盔甲。
She's quite a cynical.
她真是个愤世嫉俗的人。
I mean, in some ways that scene, let's actually talk about liberal arts.
我的意思是，在某种程度上，那一幕，让我们来谈谈《自由恋爱》。
That scene is an argument between an idealist and a cynic, You know, and I think, you know, I think we all have that conversation going on in our heads, right?
那一幕是理想主义者和愤世嫉俗者之间的辩论，你知道的，我认为，你知道的，我认为我们每个人脑海中都在进行这样的对话，对吧？
I mean, how I make your mother makes that quite explicit, you know, there's cynical stuff.
我的意思是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》把这一点表现得很明显，你知道的，里面有愤世嫉俗的内容。
There's romance and anti-romantic people and all kinds of stuff, but I think we're always at war, a little bit with the head and the heart, I think.
有浪漫主义者和反浪漫主义者以及各种各样的人，但我认为我们的理智和情感一直在进行某种程度的博弈。
Yeah, and afraid to lead too much with the heart because it feels so vulnerable.
是的，而且害怕过多地用心去引领，因为这感觉太脆弱了。
Like you were saying, that was a great message.
就像你刚才说的，那是一条很棒的信息。
Thank you for that message.
谢谢你的留言。
That is the debate, right?
这就是争论所在，对吧？
how much can we lead with our heart, how foolish will we look if we do that, and yet it's kind of the best thing to do at the same time.
我们能用心引领多少，如果我们这样做了会显得多傻，然而与此同时这又是最好的做法。
And it does feel like all the great moments in our life are the ones where we do take that leap, you know, where we circumvent the warnings of our heads, and we go for it.
而且感觉我们生命中所有伟大的时刻都是我们真正迈出那一步的时刻，你知道的，也就是我们绕过理智的警告，全力以赴的时候。
Jesse, who produced most of my movies, Jesse Harris, my friend, we always wanted to make a movie called The Hero Moment just about that kind of idea that like We have these moments in our lives.
杰西，制作了我大部分电影的人，我的朋友杰西·哈里斯，我们一直想拍一部名为《英雄时刻》的电影，就是关于那种理念：我们在生活中会有这样的时刻。
I think there's a my friend always quotes this Cameron crow Is it we bought a zoo where he says like all you need is six seconds of courage or something like that where it's That'll that'll change everything you can have those six seconds of courage It's really true.
我觉得我的朋友总是引用凯恩斯·克罗的话，是《我们买了动物园》里说的吗？他说，你只需要六秒钟的勇气之类的话，那就是——那会改变一切，你可以拥有那六秒钟的勇气，这真的很真实。
There's a few little junctures where you just have to power through Power through those moments of dad.
有几个小关头，你只需要咬牙坚持，度过那些艰难的时刻。
Well, I'm delighted to hear that how I made your mother is is good soul medicine for romantics everywhere.
听到《老爸老妈浪漫史》是各地浪漫主义者的优质心灵良药，我感到非常高兴。
And this episode under discussion today is about as romantic as how I met your mother, Gats, which is to say very romantic.
而今天我们要讨论这一集，和《老爸老妈浪漫史》一样浪漫，也就是说，非常浪漫。
Yeah, this is the perfect lead-in to this episode.
是的，这是这一集的完美引子。
Yeah, we were talking about drum roll please, which is episode 13.
是的，我们刚才在谈论“击鼓传情”，也就是第13集。
When did this air, Alec?
这是什么时候播出的，亚历克？
This aired on January 23rd, two weeks after its predecessor aired on January 9th, 2006.
这一集于1月23日播出，在其前一集于2006年1月9日播出两周后。
Yeah, I'm proud of those two weeks.
是的，我为那两周感到骄傲。
I'm proud that we waited two weeks to give you who Victoria is.
我为我们等了两周才揭晓维多利亚是谁而骄傲。
We made people really sweat it out at the end of the wedding episode.
我们在婚礼那一集的结尾让大家真正急了一把。
But that's a real cliffhanger.
但那真是一个巨大的悬念。
That was a baller move on our part.
这是我们做得很棒的一招。
We don't have the patience for that nowadays.
我们现在可没有那样的耐心了。
But we've talked about how the wedding and drum roll please are essentially one hour of television or 44 minutes of television.
但我们讨论过，婚礼和“击鼓传情”本质上是一小时的电视节目，或者说44分钟的电视节目。
It's really like it's a two-parter.
它真的很像是一个分上下集的节目。
Yeah.
是啊。
the pilot and purple giraffe in hindsight kind of feel like a two-parter.
从后见之明的角度来看，试播集和“紫色长颈鹿”感觉有点像上下集。
Although this looks like more consciously like a two-parter.
尽管这个看起来更有意地像是一个上下集。
Was it designed that way?
它是按这种方式设计的吗？
It was.
是的。
It really feels like, I watched it as an hour the other night knowing we talk about these two episodes this week and I can't think of it any other way other than it as an hour.
感觉确实如此，前几天晚上我把它当成一整集看了一小时，因为我们这周要聊这两集，除了当成一小时来看，我想不出别的办法。
It's really, really, it was hard to talk about only the first half of it last in our previous pod episode because it picks up in real time, right?
真的，真的，在上一期播客里只聊它的前半部分其实很难，因为它是实时衔接的，对吧？
ends and you come right back where you started and you were right back where you left it.
上一集结束，你马上又回到了开始的地方，回到了你离开的地方。
And I love it as an hour.
我太喜欢把它当成一个小时来看了。
I think it's really great.
我觉得这真的很棒。
I think this isn't a case where I think it's cool we made people wait two weeks and yet I think viewing it as an hour is probably the superior experience.
我觉得这不是那种“让大家等两周很酷”的情况，尽管我认为把它作为一个小时来观看可能是更好的体验。
So can you give us your quick writer's room synopsis of what happens in this episode essentially?
那你能不能给我们一个简单的编剧室梗概，讲讲这一集基本上发生了什么？
Yeah.
好。
This has one of my favorite how I met your mother's structures.
这有我最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》的结构之一。
If I'm honest, we're already, we're in episode 13 of season one, we're already ripping ourselves off because the form of this has a great resemblance to the pineapple incident, right?
说实话，我们已经拍到第一季第13集了，我们已经在抄袭我们自己了，因为这一集的套路和《菠萝疑云》非常像，对吧？
Where it's the day after and you're piecing together this mystery and clues of the night before and everyone is needed in the present day that next morning to put together the full story of what was going on last night.
都是发生在第二天，你在拼凑昨晚的谜团和线索，而且第二天早上每个人都在场，一起拼凑出昨晚到底发生了什么的完整故事。
Most of all, Robin, which is a great twist, the reveal that Robin did show up when we thought she was not gonna be able to show up to the wedding.
尤其是罗宾，这是一个很棒的反转，揭晓了罗宾其实出现了，而我们之前以为她无法出席那场婚礼。
So it is basically Ted had this amazing night with this woman, they agreed upon this idea, Victoria and Ted to not exchange information and not hear each other's last names.
所以基本上是泰德和这个女人度过了一个美妙的夜晚，维多利亚和泰德达成了一个共识：不交换信息，也不打听对方的姓氏。
So they could just have one amazing night in the context of the sea of how terrible it is to date in New York City and feel lost.
这样他们就能在纽约市糟糕透顶、让人感到迷茫的约会大环境背景下，只享受一个美妙的夜晚。
And they say, let's just make this one good night.
他们说，让我们只拥有这一个美好的夜晚吧。
We'll always hold on to this precious thing.
我们会永远铭记这份珍贵的回忆。
They wake up, or Ted wakes up alone the next morning, not having even kissed, only having done the drum roll to the kiss and explains this premise to Marshall and Lily who think he's a complete idiot, and then he has to go find this girl.
他们醒来，或者说泰德第二天早上醒来时只有自己一个人，甚至连吻都没接，只有那段不断铺垫最终却没吻成的“鼓点”，然后他把这个前提解释给马歇尔和莉莉听，他们觉得他简直是个彻底的白痴，接着他不得不去寻找这个女孩。
And then that becomes the drive of the episode.
然后这就成了这一集的剧情推动力。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，送你去纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，Hyper-Fixed播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如：我30岁了，在纽约开车很害怕。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：为什么我挂倒档时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的Hyper-Fixed播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它，或者访问 HyperFixedPod.com。
the show.
节目。
I have a question for you.
我有个问题想问你。
Was this in any way was Victoria's kind of premise of like let's not exchange real names.
维多利亚提出的那种假设，比如“我们不交换真实姓名”是这样的吗？
Let's not even let's just only have anticipation.
我们甚至不……只保留期待感。
Let's lead was any of this influenced by the end of before sunrise the first in the before trophy where at the end they say let's not exchange information.
让我们主导……这是否受到了《爱在黎明破晓前》结局的影响？也就是“爱在”三部曲的第一部，他们在结尾说，我们不要交换信息。
Let's just meet back here in what is it a year like meet back on this train platform in a year and then it's revealed yeah in the second one that he showed up and and she didn't, not to spoil, if you haven't seen those, just you can still like hold on with that information.
我们就一年后在这里见，在一年后的这个火车站台见，然后在第二部里揭晓——剧透预警，如果你没看过，你可以先捂住耳朵——他去了，而她没去。
But it does feel like there's a kind of romantic idea of like, you know, screw the world in logistics, like our hearts will lead us back to each other.
但这确实让人觉得有一种浪漫的想法，你知道的，去他的世界和后勤琐事，我们的心会指引我们重新找到彼此。
Was that, was some of that at play?
这里面是不是有这种成分在起作用？
Yeah.
是的。
I think some of that was in there because we love those movies so much.
我想这里面确实有一些这样的成分，因为我们太喜欢那些电影了。
By the way, welcome to our podcast, ruining the ending of Richard Link Better films.
顺便说一句，欢迎来到我们的播客，在这里我们毁掉了理查德·林克莱特电影的结局。
We, we're gonna do a swacker net.
我们，我们要搞个反转。
So it actually ruins the beginning of one of them.
所以它实际上毁掉了其中一部的开头。
No, but some of that was in there.
不，但这里面确实有那种成分。
I don't know how explicitly the actual thing of we're gonna almost kiss, but not kiss.
我不知道我们那种“几乎要接吻但实际上没亲”的桥段有多直白。
I think Gloria Calderon-Kellet lived this in her real life.
我想格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆-凯利特在她的现实生活中经历过这种事。
I don't remember if she was with her husband to be, who then became her husband or if it was with somebody else.
我不记得她当时是和她后来的丈夫在一起，还是和别人在一起。
There was some circumstance where I think that she and somebody else did this, knowing that they shouldn't go any further for whatever reason.
某种情况下，我觉得她和另外一个人这样做了，出于某种原因，他们知道自己不应该再深入下去了。
And I think it was sparked literally by something in real life.
而且我认为这完全是由现实生活中的某件事引发的。
The whole sort of like larger premise of the episode definitely relates to some of those big rom com swings.
这一集整体上那种宏大的前提，绝对和那些宏大的浪漫喜剧套路有关。
And that's that idea of like, let's meet up on the top in the Empire State Building a year from now, I forget what, what all the movie that was, I'm completely wagging on what that one was.
这就是那种想法，比如，一年后的今天我们在帝国大厦顶层见面吧，我忘了那是哪部电影了，我完全记不起那是哪一部了。
But for sure, we were tapping into some of those kind of like big swing romantic comedy contrivances, contrivances in the best possible sense of the term.
但可以肯定的是，我们正在触及那些宏大的浪漫喜剧桥段，用这个词最好的意义来说，就是精心的桥段。
It strikes me that her, the offering she makes, or the idea she has, is on some level an incredibly wildly romantic thing.
我发现她提出的建议，或者她的想法，在某种程度上是一种极其疯狂的浪漫。
It's saying the anticipation and the lead up to it, to whatever it is, is always the best, least complicated part where it's only the promise of something.
这就是说，对某件事的期待和铺垫，无论那是什么，永远都是最好、最简单、只有美好承诺的部分。
Where there's a bit of like a wounded undertone of the whole thing is like it gets messy after that.
整个事情背后有一种隐隐作痛的潜台词，那就是之后一切都会变得一团糟。
So she's in some ways trying to extract like alchemy, like just pull the gold out of the thing, you know, and leave the lead for some other experience, right?
所以她在某些方面试图提取炼金术，就像从事物中提炼出黄金，你知道的，把铅留给其他经历，对吧？
So it's both romantic, but it's also evidence for both of them that they've been through it.
所以这既是浪漫的，但对他们两人来说，这也是他们经历过沧桑的证明。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
They're really both trying to create circumstances where they don't have to deal with collateral damage, the shrapnel of things going wrong.
他们两个其实都在努力创造这样一种环境：他们不必面对附带的损害，不必面对事情出错带来的残局。
Yes, that's right, baked into the cake is the wounds that they've already gotten and they're only like in their late 20s, which is interesting.
是的，没错，这一切的基础就是他们已经受过的伤，而且他们当时才二十多岁，这很有趣。
It does add kind of like without saying it, it adds kind of this gravitas to all the proceedings that follow and they're avoiding heartbreak by needing this one good thing.
它确实在没有明说的情况下，为随后的所有情节增添了一种庄严感，他们通过需要这件美好的事来逃避心碎。
The problem is the morning after when they wanted to keep knowing each other.
问题是第二天早上，当他们想继续了解彼此的时候。
The mind is constantly on the hunt for ease, frictionlessness, no problems, zero effort.
人的大脑时刻都在寻找轻松、无摩擦、没有问题、零费力的状态。
And the universe is always like, yeah, that's not how it works.
而宇宙总是说，是的，事情可不是这样的。
That's simply not how it works.
事情根本不是这样的。
Like you're going to have to step in it, you know?
比如你还是得踩进去，你知道吗？
Yeah, it feels like a slight corollary to like, cheating on the test is sort of as much work as just studying for the test, you know what I mean?
是的，这感觉有点像是，作弊考试其实和复习考试一样费力，你知道我的意思吗？
Like you can't, like it's gonna get you one way or the other.
就像你逃不掉的，总有一天会找上你。
Oh yeah, so we actually have a question on this topic, You know, we're not going to be doing a general questions.
哦，对，所以我们其实在这个主题上有一个问题，你知道的，我们不会做一般性提问。
General questions?
一般性提问？
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well done.
干得好。
Continue.
继续。
Episode.
剧集。
But I did get a great question just on this topic of the kiss.
但我确实收到了一个关于“亲吻”这个主题的好问题。
And by the way, for in a couple of weeks, we will do another general questions that will collect your questions from this one.
顺便说一句，过几周我们会做另一个一般性提问，收集你们这次的问题。
So please hold on to your general questions questions for this episode.
所以请把你们关于这一集的一般性问题留到那时候。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
And here is one from a fan.
这里有一个来自粉丝的问题。
Okay.
好的。
Hi, everybody.
大家好。
I played Victoria on the show how I met your mother.
我在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里扮演维多利亚。
Listen, I just got word that you're going to be watching drumroll, please.
听着，我刚刚得到消息，你们要看——请敲鼓。
Now, confession, when I got that information that you're going to be watching drumroll, please, I was like, wait, there's also an episode called The Wedding, which is drumroll and which is the wedding, because aren't they both the wedding?
现在，坦白说，当我得知你们要看《请敲鼓》时，我在想，等等，还有一集叫《婚礼》，哪个是《请敲鼓》，哪个是《婚礼》，因为它们不都是婚礼吗？
Anyway, hopefully, now that you've watched, you've deciphered.
不管怎样，希望现在你们看过了，已经解开谜团了。
Um, I, that was, I believe my first episode of the show, unless it was the wedding, which one's the wedding.
嗯，那，我相信那是我的第一集节目，除非那是《婚礼》，到底哪个是《婚礼》。
Can I get Mrs. Dint?
能给我一点提示吗？
Anyway, I would just said, do you have any questions for them?
不管怎样，我刚才说的是，你们有什么问题要问他们吗？
Did anybody else feel like it was like a little intense that she said no kissing?
有没有人觉得她说“不准接吻”有点太强烈了？
Right?
对吧？
Like, I disagree.
就像，我不同意。
Oh.
哦。
Look, before the kiss is great, why couldn't they have kissed, kept their eyes closed, separated.
听着，亲吻前的情节很棒，为什么他们就不能亲一下，然后闭上眼睛，分开呢。
Oh boy.
天哪。
Am I wrong?
难道我错了吗？
Disguise.
伪装。
Oh my God, they do actually so much to see her face meet me happy.
哦天哪，他们为了看到她的脸高兴，其实付出了很多。
Here's Ashley's dedication to this.
这是阿什莉对这事的投入。
She's in Bulgaria right now.
她现在在保加利亚。
We were emailing about her eventual visit here, and I said, we are recording this in one hour.
我们通过邮件讨论她以后来这里的访问，我说，我们一小时后就要录音了。
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
I only thought of this right now.
我刚刚才想到这个。
Would you mind asking a question and she's like?
你介意问个问题吗，然后她说？
Absolutely, so that just him in that's hot off the presses.
当然，所以这是刚刚新鲜出炉的。
That is unbelievable.
这太令人难以置信了。
Just what a treat.
真是个惊喜。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thanks for that.
Um The best yeah, you know what it's she's so right like drumroll please could have been the one before and then the wedding Could have the titles are confusing by the way just to say it the wedding should have been called plus one Oh, I was watching the wedding and I'm like there's a billion fucking things that could be called the wedding.
嗯，最棒的，是的，你知道吗，她是那么对，比如《请敲鼓》本可以是之前的那集，然后《婚礼》可以是一集，顺便说一句，这些标题让人很混淆，我想说的是，《婚礼》本应该叫《加一》。哦，我在看《婚礼》的时候我就想，有无数他妈的事情都可以叫《婚礼》。
The whole debate, the whole symposium is did check, did Ted check plus one.
整场辩论，整个研讨会讨论的是泰德有没有带女伴。
That's right, that's right.
没错，没错。
It should have been called plus one.
它本来应该叫《加一》的。
I'm just gonna add every few episodes, I'm gonna just gonna regretfully say.
我只是想补充一句，每隔几集，我就会懊悔地说出这句话。
You know what I think?
你知道我觉得怎么样吗？
They say that, you know, our questions reveal about it.
他们说，我们的问题暴露了我们的内心。
Like, I think we just learned like Ashley loves kissing.
比如，我觉得我们刚刚了解到阿什莉热爱接吻。
She loves kissing.
她热爱接吻。
She doesn't care about the lead-up.
她不在乎铺垫。
She likes the main event.
她喜欢重头戏。
This is the other neutral or a compliment to you.
这绝对不是贬义，或者说是个赞美。
It's definitely not bad.
绝对不是坏事。
She was either open to wanting to kiss you or really wanted to kiss you.
她要么是愿意和你接吻，要么是非常想和你接吻。
But it's a fair question.
但这是一个公平的问题。
It's also funny that we're in a time in whatever human history where not kissing is considered kind of like radical, right?
有趣的是，我们现在处在人类历史的某个时期，不接吻竟然被认为有点激进，对吧？
Like, you know, like in old-timey things like a knees touching under the table, we're just charged with so much erotic energy because it was like, you wouldn't be touching.
就像，你知道的，在老派的事情里，比如桌子底下膝盖相碰，都会充满了强烈的色情能量，因为那时你们不会触碰。
You wouldn't be holding hands like these things that historically have been like big leaps are now just, I don't know, just a good night out, you know?
你们不会手拉手，这些在历史上被视为巨大飞跃的事情，现在却只是，我不知道，只是一次愉快的约会，你知道吗？
Totally.
完全赞同。
I mean, look, it isn't, she has this master plan.
我是说，听着，这并不是说她有什么宏伟计划。
It is a little bit intense, but I think the answer to the question is what we were just talking about before our she's clip, which is, there's some wound just behind that thing, right?
这确实有点强烈，但我觉得这个问题的答案就是我们刚才在播放她的剪辑之前谈论的内容，那就是，在那件事背后隐藏着某种伤痛，对吧？
She's like, but she's acknowledging that maybe that she has and she assumes Ted has rushed into some shit that has ruined whatever magic began that spark.
她像是，但她也承认也许她有，而且她假设泰德也曾冲动地陷入某些事情中，从而毁掉了最初产生火花的魔力。
And she says, can we, it should be just preserve like this like precious little flame in our hands, like a jack-lend and short story.
她说，我们能不能，就像捧着手中珍贵的小火苗一样，把它完好保存下来，就像杰克·伦敦短篇小说里那样。
Like can we just preserve this one little thing just to keep us hopeful moving forward in life?
我们能不能仅仅保存这件小事，来让我们对未来的人生保持希望？
And then we'll never see it.
然后我们就再也不见面了。
It's an intense idea, but it's born of some sort of a scar, you know?
这是一个强烈的想法，但它源于某种创伤，你知道吗？
Right, right.
对，对。
But also, you know, there's a lot of talk about Barney loving good stories.
而且，你知道，大家总在讨论巴尼喜欢好故事。
and Barney always trying to create the stories, but Ted's a lover of a good story from a different angle.
巴尼总是试图创造故事，但泰德是从另一个角度喜欢好故事。
And this is like, when she suggests this, it's kind of like, all right, like I'll try anything once, you know?
当她提出这个建议时，这有点像，好吧，我什么都愿意尝试一次，你知道吗？
And I think like Ted is always, he's always a little bit like, his first impulse is to act cooler than he actually is, which is, you know, like with Robin in Purple Draft, like, I can be chill, you know?
而且我觉得泰德总是这样，他的第一冲动总是表现得比实际上更酷，你知道的，就像在《紫草稿》里对罗宾那样，我可以很淡定，你知道吗？
I can not carry my heart to unengaged.
我可以不把心全盘托出。
I'm just a dude.
我只是个普通人。
But then he's like, oh, no.
但随后他又会觉得，哦，不。
Like, I really, you know, he's got a little bit of a, like, you know what's better than a little bit of a good thing is a lot of a good thing, you know?
比如，我真的很，你知道，他有点那种，你知道比一点点好事更好的是什么吗？是大量的好事，你知道吗？
Yes.
是的。
And also, I think, you know, we love, I think, leaving like a little trace of something, like to spoil the ending.
而且我觉得，我们喜欢，留下一点点事物的痕迹，比如剧透结局。
I mean, if you're listening to this, we assume you've watched.
我是说，如果你在听这个，我们假设你已经看过了。
We have to at least be able to spoil the ending of the episode we're talking about.
我们至少得把我们正在谈论的那集的结局给剧透一下。
Yeah, but there's something about Victoria's, thank God, that is so great.
对，但谢天谢地，维多利亚身上有一种特质真的很棒。
It's such a good episode.
这一集真的太棒了。
Like, it feels like, I find myself very moved by now.
就感觉……我现在发现自己真的很受触动。
Very, very.
非常非常受触动。
There's something very deeply moving about that moment.
那个时刻有一种非常深沉感人的力量。
And also like the subtle thing of Ted putting on the bleach stain sweatshirt.
还有泰德穿上那件有漂白剂污渍的运动衫这种微妙的细节。
Yeah, I love that.
对，我太喜欢这个了。
So it's such a cool move because it's like he is suiting up for her.
这真的是个绝妙的举动，就好像他在为她披挂上阵一样。
Like it's his, it's his suiting up.
就像那是他的……那是他的战袍。
But also her thank God is almost like, I left you just enough breadcrumbs to find me.
但她那句“谢天谢地”几乎也像是在说：“我给你留了刚刚好的面包屑，足够你找到我了。”
Yeah, totally.
对，完全是这样。
Like good, good metaphor for a baker, breadcrumbs.
作为一个面包师，面包屑真是一个绝妙的隐喻。
Well, that's right, that's right.
嗯，没错，确实如此。
I left it, I left it enough, just enough powdered sugar trail for you to find it.
我留下了……我留下了刚刚好的糖粉足迹，好让你能顺藤摸瓜找到它。
but it feels like it feels like it's also evidence of his cleverness and his listening, right?
但这感觉也证明了他的聪明才智和他的倾听能力，对吧？
Like he was able to Sherlock his way towards her.
就像他像福尔摩斯一样抽丝剥茧找到了她。
Yeah, and coming in so unadorned the opposite of the bravado that like Barney would exhibit, right?
对，而且他出场时那么朴素，完全没有巴尼那种虚张声势的样子，对吧？
Barney's like, my suit says everything about me, Ted, saying I want to show you who I really am and who you seem to want to see, the real me, in the stand sweatswet shirt.
巴尼总是说：“我的西装说明了我的一切，泰德。”而泰德穿着那件带漂白剂污渍的运动衫，却仿佛在说：“我想让你看到真实的我，看到你似乎想见的那个真正的我。”
And like there's something so after this night where they're in tuxedos and wedding dresses and whatnot, the next day to come in without any armor at all.
在经历了昨晚那种大家都穿着燕尾服和婚纱的盛装之夜后，第二天却能不加任何伪装地出现，这种感觉真的很奇妙。
He did the literal opposite Barney.
他做了和巴尼完全相反的事。
He suited down, you know, he literally, Barney says, seat up, dead seats down.
他卸下了战袍，你知道的，字面意义上的。巴尼说“穿上西装”，泰德则是“脱下西装”。
And there's something so sweet about that.
这其中有一种非常甜蜜的感觉。
Yeah.
对。
I love that.
我太喜欢这个了。
It feels like it's this whole evening, somewhat Ted engineers it, but also it's the fate is on his side, at least in this night.
感觉整个晚上，虽然泰德在某种程度上有意策划，但命运也站在他这一边，至少在这个夜晚是这样的。
because I imagine, and this is where there is a little overlap with me and Ted, like I was not at a wedding in, or any party like, unless I was really on something, but I was at the center of the dance floor, you know, going crazy.
因为我想象——这也是我和泰德有点重合的地方，我以前参加婚礼或者任何派对时——除非我真的嗑嗨了，否则我才不会去舞池中央发疯呢。
I was always hoping to, and not even in a romantic context, like my favorite moments of parties are like, when you fall into that great conversation in the corner, you know, you can really go deep and kind of like be off to the side.
我总是希望能——甚至都不是出于浪漫的上下文，我最喜欢的派对时刻是，当你和某人在角落里开始一场精彩的对话，你知道的，可以进行深入的交流，就待在稍微旁边一点的地方。
And this is a whole evening of that for him.
对他来说，整个晚上都是这样的体验。
He falls in with this woman who's just a great, I mean, she's clearly like witty and funny and she seems to share a kind of romantic ideal with him.
他遇到了这个女人，她不仅很棒——我的意思是，她显然很机智、很有趣，而且她似乎和他在浪漫理想上有着某种共鸣。
It's perfect.
这太完美了。
I mean, it's a, it's a, Moseby could not have scripted this better in some ways, you know?
我是说，莫斯比在某些方面简直不能把剧本写得更好了，对吧？
The universe is giving us time.
命运正在给我们时间。
And even the, you know, I think even though we long for ease and we long for frictionlessness, we act, what we actually want is just enough struggle so that we get to the other side of it and it feels great.
而且即使——你知道的，我认为尽管我们渴望轻松和毫无摩擦的生活，但实际上我们真正想要的是恰到好处的挣扎，这样当我们熬过难关时，感觉才会格外美妙。
So I think that's why the ending is so satisfying.
所以我觉得这就是结局为什么如此令人满意的原因。
Like he had to sleuth his way back to her and her relief at seeing him and his relief at seeing her.
就像他必须通过寻踪觅迹回到她身边，她看到他时的如释重负，以及他看到她时的如释重负。
And now we can finally kiss.
然后我们终于可以接吻了。
It's almost like they really earned it, you know?
这感觉就像他们真的是凭实力赢得了这一切，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
And I think she made Ted earn it, right?
而且我觉得是她让泰德付出了努力，对吧？
She's kind of laid down some gauntlets and some obstacles.
她抛出了一些挑战和障碍。
Like if you can, if you can trace this bread crumb pass and do these things and kind of show me, you're like, man, show me you're worthy of me.
就好像：如果你能顺着这个面包屑的线索找到我，完成这些事情，并向我证明——老兄，向我证明你配得上我。
And he proves himself worthy.
然后他证明了自己配得上。
It's really kind of a hero's journey in this episode.
这一集真的有点像英雄的旅程。
And Ted is so undaunted by any of that.
而且泰德对这一切都毫不畏惧。
I find Ted not to, I don't want to create an unsafe workplace for you, Josh, but I find Ted very sexy in this episode.
我觉得泰德面对这一切时——乔什，我可不想在你的工作场所制造不安全感，但我发现泰德这一集真的性感得不行。
Yes.
没错。
He's got a lot of swagger.
他自带满满的自信。
He's got a lot of like confident swagger in this one.
他在这一集里有一种非常自信潇洒的帅气。
I was just like, Ted's got some fucking game in this one.
我当时就觉得：泰德这回可真有两下子啊！
like very just yes and very like completely she nothing she's thrown down is thrown him off and he is very he's a confident the whole way.
就那种“完全赞同”的态度，而且无论她抛出什么状况都没把他难倒，他全程都极其自信。
It's great.
太棒了。
It's like he let go of this idea of he was going to take Robin to the wedding and the part one of this.
这就像他放下了在第一部分里“要带罗宾去婚礼”的执念。
He's let go of this what it has to be.
他放下了那些“必须如何”的条条框框。
And he finds this woman who lays down this whole new series of challenges and says like, yep, what's next?
然后他遇到了这个女人，她提出了全新的一系列挑战，而他则说：“行啊，接下来是什么？”
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
I really like that.
我真的很喜欢这一点。
I would argue that maybe Ted is like, at least in these early episodes, like he's like 83% smooth to use a percentage that is famously how I met your mother, he's 83% smooth and then there's the 17% where he can't stop.
我会说，也许泰德——至少在这些早期的剧集中——他有大约83%的顺畅度——借用一个《老爸老妈浪漫史》里著名的百分比——他有83%的顺畅，然后剩下的17%是他根本停不下来。
His most mean, the I love he comes in.
我的意思是，他一登场的时候……
Like the thing that he, it's almost like he needs to work on impulse control.
就像他做的那件事，感觉他几乎需要提高一下冲动控制能力。
It's like the famous study of like delayed gratification, you know, with the kids and the cookies and everything.
就像那个著名的延迟满足实验，你知道的，关于小孩子和曲奇饼干那些。
Like he still needs some remedial work on that.
他在这方面显然还需要进行一些补习。
But it's also funny when you say, you know, it's like this mythic challenge, like I imagine speaking of college courses on how I met your mothers, didn't someone say at the limo they did like a paper on gender wax and in the 2000s comedies.
但有趣的是，当你提到——你知道的，这就像是一场神话般的挑战——说到关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》的大学课程，有没有人在加长轿车那一幕里提到过，他们在2000年代的喜剧里做过一篇关于性别角力的论文？
There's something, you know, you have so many, are they called boons like the object that you have to?
这里面有一些东西，你知道，你有那么多……它们叫什么来着，就像你必须去获取的那种“宝物”？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, like in a hero's journey.
对，就像在英雄的旅程中那样。
Yeah, I think so.
对，我想是的。
I know.
我知道。
Yeah.
对。
So there is something like you guys are creating a contemporary myth.
所以这里面确实有种你们在创造当代神话的感觉。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, she's up in the castle, she's up, it really is like Ted has to find his way up to the damsel.
对，她高居城堡之上，她就在上面，这真的很像泰德必须披荆斩棘去寻找落难公主。
Like, there's something very, or- She makes herself untouchable.
这其中有一种非常——或者说，她把自己变得高不可攀。
There's also something about romantic comedies where I've heard that it's harder to write romantic comedies now, and this kind of goes back to what we were talking about, like Victorian eyes across the room or fingertips touching was so hot and so laden with subtext and all this stuff.
浪漫喜剧中还有这样一种现象，我听说现在要写浪漫喜剧更难了——这有点回到我们刚才讨论的话题——以前那种隔着房间深情对望或是指尖触碰的桥段就足够让人心动，充满了言外之意和各种情绪。
But now that people are just allowed to allow, you know, you know, times have changed, you meet up, you're attracted to them, you you sleep with them, you don't sleep with it, it doesn't.
但现在人们都被允许——你知道的，时代变了，你相亲，你被对方吸引，然后你们上床，或者不上床，这都没什么大不了的。
There's not a lot of Roblox, but romantic comedies are all about what's in the way of the couples getting together.
障碍没那么多了，但浪漫喜剧的核心恰恰在于有什么阻碍了情侣们在一起。
Yeah.
对。
Sometimes it's part of their character.
有时候障碍是他们性格的一部分。
Sometimes it's like a family is in the way.
有时候就像是某个家庭在从中作梗。
Or people have created like, like distance, you know, sleepless in Seattle is all like they're in different areas of, you know, so it feels like you guys writing this classic, but also at the time, like fresh take on the romantic comedy, you have to create.
或者人们人为制造了距离，你知道的，《西雅图夜未眠》里他们就在不同的地方，所以感觉你们在写这部经典之作时，同时也是在对浪漫喜剧进行一种在当时看来很新鲜的尝试，你们必须去创造障碍。
So it's like what I would say to Ashley as, as lovely and hilarious as her observation is, is, well, why does she do that?
所以我要对阿什莉说的是，尽管她的观察既可爱又搞笑，但——“好吧，她为什么要这么做？”
So we have a good 22 minute episode of television, you know, to create an obstacle, so it does feel a little strange by our standard, but also like, when everyone's doing one thing, there can be a lot that you discover by doing, going the opposite direction.
为了让我们能有一集精彩的22分钟电视剧，为了制造一个障碍，所以按我们的标准来看可能觉得有点奇怪，但同时，当所有人都走同一条路时，通过反其道而行之，你往往能发现很多新大陆。
Yeah, totally.
对，完全同意。
Here's my question about Victoria at that wedding.
关于维多利亚在那个婚礼上的表现，我有这样一个疑问。
First of all, is it plausible that a baker is there at the wedding the whole time?
首先，一个蛋糕师整场婚礼都待在现场，这合理吗？
Second, if the baker of the wedding cake was there, the one thing they should do is be there to cut and serve the cake and like oversee that part of it.
其次，如果婚礼蛋糕师当时就在现场，她最应该做的事就是留下来切蛋糕、分蛋糕，并监督好那个环节。
Victoria fucking bails on that so hard.
维多利亚居然把这事给甩得干干净净。
She disappears from wedding, they come back, the wedding's over, the cake's gone.
她从婚礼上消失了，等大家回来时，婚礼结束了，蛋糕也没了。
I say that Victoria a little bit had one job at that wedding and she blew it.
我认为维多利亚在那场婚礼上其实就只有一项工作，结果她却搞砸了。
She was like, hey, she got it went off on a whole other narrative.
她就像是——嘿，她自己跑去开启了一条完全不同的故事线。
And I kind of love that, but it really caught my eye this time.
我其实挺喜欢这一点的，但这次看的时候确实太扎眼了。
Every single episode, you could say like, this is the narrative like trick we pulled or like, this shouldn't have been by all logical standards, this makes no sense.
每一集你都可以说：这就是我们用的叙事诡计，或者说：按常理来讲这根本说不通。
But again, you're trying, you're rigging the mystery, right?
但话又说回来，你们是在精心布置这个谜团，对吧？
Like, like, it's a really great moment and Claudius says there was no one named Victoria, my wet.
就像——这是一个非常棒的时刻，克劳迪娅说我的婚礼上根本没有叫维多利亚的人。
Oh my God, there were so many good moments, little twists along the way.
哦天哪，有太多精彩的时刻了，一路上到处都是小反转。
I think the best time I've had some other episodes are many mysteries within this larger series mystery of how does Ted find this woman and to have these kids and what is Ted's future, how does he get there?
我觉得我最喜欢的其他剧集时刻，是这个跨越十年的宏大主线谜团（即泰德如何找到这个女人、拥有这些孩子、他的未来会怎样、他是如何走到那一步的）之中包含的许多小型谜团。宏观来看，这是一个极其宏大、长达十年的巨大谜团，但它的DNA、它的微小元素本身就是这些有趣的小谜团，其中很多最棒的谜团都是这样，比如凤梨、山羊，还有这一集。
It's a larger, writ large, it is this enormous, arcing decade long mystery kind of, but the DNA, the little ingredients of it are themselves, these little mysteries, a lot of the best ones, pineapple and cinneth, this one.
我喜欢所有的反转和曲折。
I love all the twists and turns.
I love, there's no Victoria at this wedding.
我喜欢，这场婚礼上没有维多利亚。
I love, and the reveal that Robin did actually come to the wedding is a great twist and heartbreaking.
我喜欢，而且罗宾确实来了婚礼这个转折真的很棒，也很虐心。
It really tells you a lot all at once and then it becomes about that and you didn't see that coming.
它一下子告诉你很多信息，然后故事就围绕这个展开，而你完全没料到这一点。
I really like that twist this time.
我真的很喜欢这次的转折。
Well, you guys, I think we're really masterful at the withholding information, you know?
好吧，伙计们，我觉得我们在信息保留方面真的很有一套，你知道吗？
Like deciding how to dole it out.
比如决定如何一点点透露。
Yeah.
对。
And creating some sense of disorientation that ultimately gets solved.
并制造某种最终会被解开的迷茫感。
So even though you were teasing the audience with this long nine year mystery within each episode or many episodes, you could almost like do a thing on like different classifications of episodes, like mystery, you could say, like there are a bunch of other episodes that are almost like just proper mysteries.
所以，尽管你们在每一集或很多集中用这个长达九年的谜团来挑逗观众，你几乎可以做个关于不同剧集分类的事情，比如悬疑，你可以说，还有很多其他剧集几乎就是真正的悬疑剧。
You know, Tim Mosby Architect is a mystery.
你知道，建筑师蒂姆·莫斯比就是一个谜。
There's a lot of them.
有很多这样的集数。
There's like every third episode, it's like it's some version of that, every fifth one anyway.
差不多每三集就有一集是那种风格的变体，反正每五集里也有一集。
Yeah, so you do get the narrative satisfaction of like a smaller scale mystery solved.
对，所以你确实能获得解开一个小规模谜团的叙事满足感。
Yeah, yeah, I think it's really fun.
对，对，我觉得这真的很有趣。
It's really fun.
真的很有趣。
And when you realize that Claudia, who knows every inch of this wedding does not recognize the name Victoria, that's a great, this has good act breaks.
当你意识到对这场婚礼了如指掌的克劳迪娅竟然不认识“维多利亚”这个名字时，这太棒了，这集的幕间停顿（Act break）处理得很好。
But would she also not know the name of the baker?
但她难道不也应该知道蛋糕师的名字吗？
I know, I know, I had a little bit of that moment too.
我知道，我知道，我当时也有过这种感觉。
There's a few guys in here.
这里有几个家伙。
It's Stuart and Claudia being their best friends, all of a sudden just for this one episode, these two episodes, Victoria.
斯图尔特和克劳迪娅作为他们最好的朋友，突然在这单独的一集、这两集里，冒出了维多利亚。
Yeah, there's a few buzz.
对，有一些漏洞。
Also, isn't it one of the first things you say at a wedding, are you here for the bride or the groom?
还有，你在婚礼上说的第一句话不应该是“你是为新郎来的还是为新娘来的”吗？
Or like, how are you here?
或者类似，“你是怎么来的？”
Yeah, they probably would have covered this, but they did agree to this kind of clandestine, like we're not gonna give each other too much information or context.
对，他们可能本可以掩盖过去，但他们确实同意了这种秘密的形式，比如“我们不会给对方太多信息或背景”。
So I do, I guess you could buy it.
所以我想，你大概也能说得过去。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
还有这个老头，他……爱上了你，然后是广告，广告结束，回到节目。
Boy, you were just a doctor for a second about Ashley again, like first of all, she comes on and there's like a 20 second clip of her and like your day is better, just even see, she's one of those people like you see her, you hear her voice your days just a little bit better.
天哪，刚才有一秒钟你又成了阿什莉的狂热粉丝，首先，她一出场，就是一个大概20秒的她的剪辑，你的心情就会变好，甚至只是看到她，听到她的声音，你的心情就会稍微变好一点。
You guys had such a great connection right away.
你们俩一见面就有一种非常棒的默契。
And of course we wanted the audience to think this could be the mother, right?
当然，我们希望观众认为她可能是孩子的母亲，对吧？
We didn't dispel, we didn't confirm or deny that.
我们没有消除这种猜测，也没有证实或否认。
We made people wait two weeks back when these episodes used to be every Monday and not all at once to figure out who she was.
当这些剧集过去每周一播出而不是一次性放出时，我们让大家等了两个星期才弄清楚她是谁。
What's your memory of you get thrown into this one of Ted's greatest rom-com outings, I think, right?
你对被卷入泰德最棒的浪漫喜剧出场之一有什么记忆吗？我觉得是这样的，对吧？
The wedding plus drum roll that hour is one of the best Ted romantic comedy, kind of its own mini little movie.
婚礼加上《鼓声》（Drumroll）那一小时是泰德最好的浪漫喜剧之一，有点像它自己的微型小电影。
How did you feel?
你当时感觉怎么样？
How did you announce that?
你是怎么宣布这一点的？
Can you ask you a little bit, right?
能问你一点吗，对吧？
you guys connect, how did you feel working with her like this, like in this very intense way at all of a sudden?
你们很合拍，突然之间以这种非常强烈的方式和她合作，你感觉怎么样？
I think the charm and the ease one feels watching her as Victoria, you know, the kind of open.
我觉得看着她饰演维多利亚时，人们会感受到一种迷人和轻松，你知道那种开放的感觉。
There's like a silliness to her, like in the best kind of way, like a kind of like she can be both sincere and such a goofball, which is so charming.
她身上有一种傻乎乎的特质，是以最好的一种方式，既能真诚又能当个十足的活宝，这太迷人了。
And I think, I don't know, I immediately felt like this allyship with her.
而且我觉得，我不知道，我立刻就对她产生了一种同盟感。
I felt like, oh, this is a great addition to the cast for this story we're telling, and also just like a really great person to be in the trenches with.
我觉得，哦，对于我们正在讲的故事来说，这是演员阵容中极好的一员，而且也是一个非常适合并肩作战的好伙伴。
I mean, she had done a lot of stuff and she knew the drill.
我的意思是，她演过很多作品，她懂这一行。
I think sitcom acting is deceptively hard.
我认为情景喜剧表演有着欺骗性的难度。
Yeah.
对。
I think the best ones make it look quite easy.
我觉得最棒的演员能把它演得看起来很简单。
It's like, that's part of the trick of it, is that it looks kind of easy.
这就像是其中的诀窍之一，就是它看起来挺容易的。
But I remember feeling, especially in drum roll, like I remember reading drum roll and being like, oh yeah, this is a good one for Ted, yeah.
但我记得当时的感觉，尤其是在拍《鼓声》的时候，我记得读《鼓声》的剧本时就在想，“哦，是的，这对泰德来说是个好故事，是的。”
This is really good.
这真的很棒。
And I liked getting to be heroic romantically.
而且我很喜欢在浪漫方面表现得很英勇。
I thought like, if I'm asked to do one big thing in this show, it's to be like a romantic hero, like via hero for open-hearted, sincere, vulnerable dudes everywhere who really wanna meet someone and go for it, you know?
我觉得，如果在这部剧里让我做一件大事，那就是做一个浪漫的英雄，为天下所有心胸坦荡、真诚、脆弱、真正想遇到某人并勇往直前的男人们当英雄，你知道吗？
And I think it was an untapped market like by the evidence of many men and women saying I relate to Ted so much, you know?
我觉得这是一个未被开发的市场，从许多男人和女人说“我和泰德太有共鸣了”就能看出这一点，你知道吗？
So I think you guys really hit on an archetype that had been kind of unexplored because I think the idea was in culture like most men are like Barney, like they just, you know, the, you know, the old ball and chain, I don't want to be, you know, I'd rather be out with the boys or I'd rather be, you know, meeting someone.
所以我觉得你们确实触及了一种在文化中一直未被怎么探讨的原型，因为我觉得当时的文化观念是，大多数男人就像巴尼那样，你知道的，你知道那种“家有贤妻（老绊脚石）”的心态，我才不要，你知道的，我宁愿跟哥们儿出去，或者我宁愿去……你知道的，去认识别人。
And I think you guys just wrote this guy that I helped bring to life with you that was a different breed, but really way more common than we realized.
而我觉得你们塑造了这个角色——我和你们一起把它带到了生活中——他是一个不同品种的男人，但实际上比我们意识到的要常见得多。
And I also remember as the scenes wore on, like I remember like when the bow tie kind of came untied like I felt really like I was both as a character like really dropped into the moment very relaxed in a kind of like young Richard Gere.
我还记得随着场景的推进，就像我记得当领结解开的时候，我真的感觉自己既作为角色完全沉浸在当下，又非常放松，有点像年轻时的理查·基尔。
You know, like it just felt like easy and Ashley has that thing of like if she's supposed to be attracted to you, you feel attractive.
你知道的，就感觉一切都很轻松，而阿什莉身上有一种特质：如果她本该被你吸引，你就会觉得自己很有吸引力。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like she's got that like generous quality as an actress where she's helping you.
她作为演员有一种慷慨的品质，她在帮衬着你。
You know, she's really playing long.
你知道的，她真的很配合。
She laughs at your jokes in just the right way that makes you feel like, you know what, I'm pretty funny.
她恰到好处地对你的笑话笑出声来，让你觉得，你知道吗，我其实挺搞笑的。
You know, and you're like, I don't know if that's Victoria or Ashley, but it's making me feel good.
你知道，你会想，我不知道这是维多利亚还是阿什莉，但这让我感觉很好。
So yeah, totally.
所以，是的，完全如此。
Yeah, I thought she was, I mean, I couldn't imagine anyone else playing the role.
对，我觉得她，我的意思是，我无法想象其他人来演这个角色。
She's she was fantastic.
她太棒了。
And she was always just a delight to have on set.
而且她在片场总是让人感到非常开心。
She was always, she's one of those actors that always look like delighted to be there.
她总是，她是那种看起来总是很高兴能来到这里的演员。
You know, She has that twinkle in her eye.
你知道，她眼里有光。
She just has that thing.
她身上就是有那种特质。
It's just like a little bit magic.
这就像是带有一点魔力。
It kind of can't be faked or learned or practiced.
这种特质是无法伪造、学习或练习出来的。
She has that thing.
她身上就有那种东西。
And also, just a shout out, like she's been shown up for these Paul Grossfield events for years, you know, to help us raise money.
还有，顺便提一句，多年来她一直出席保罗·格罗斯菲尔德（Paul Grossfield）的这些活动，你知道的，来帮我们筹集资金。
Yeah, I know.
对，我知道。
I wanted to point that out too.
我也想指出这一点。
All these years later, we do these, our band, the solids, we did the How Much Mother theme song and like Carter and I, it's a card on my band.
多年后的今天，我们还在做这些，我们的乐队The Solids，我们创作了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的主题曲，我和卡特，那是卡特和我的乐队。
And we wrote a lot of the silly song, How Much Mother.
我们写了这首傻乎乎的歌《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
And we do a charity fundraiser concert every year, past few years, we're going to keep doing it.
过去几年里，我们每年都举办一次慈善募捐音乐会，我们还会继续办下去。
I will very much plug it on this show.
我非常乐意在这档节目里为它做宣传。
It'll be some months away, the next one.
距离下一场还有好几个月。
But Ashley always comes out and does the song list.
但阿什莉总是会来献唱。
We did Victoria by the Kinks, which we use later in the series, spoilers.
我们唱了The Kinks的《Victoria》，我们在剧集后期也用了这首歌，剧透预警。
Ashley, you can tell by how much we love her.
阿什莉，从我们有多爱她就能看出来。
She comes back later if you're watching the show for the first time.
如果你是第一次看这部剧，你会发现她后来又回归了。
Sorry, but I'm not sorry because you get more Ashley and so you're welcome.
很抱歉，但我一点也不觉得抱歉，因为你能看到更多阿什莉，所以不用谢。
And so she comes out and she just she has such pride for having been part of how much her mother and she's such an open-hearted, amazing person that she loves to help raise money for this good cause, that the cause is to do research into congenital heart conditions for pediatric, you know, basically kids like my son who had open heart surgery, had any kind of congenital heart defect.
所以她来了，她为自己曾参演《老爸老妈的浪漫史》感到无比骄傲，她是一个如此心胸宽广、了不起的人，她喜欢为这个美好的原因筹集资金，这个原因就是研究小儿先天性心脏病，你知道的，基本上就是像我儿子那样做过心脏手术、患有任何先天性心脏缺陷的孩子。
This is raising money to research into that.
这是在为相关的研究筹集资金。
And she just like, she shows up, she flies from LA to New York to be part of the concert.
她就这样出席了，她从洛杉矶飞到纽约来参加这场音乐会。
Josh has done every one of them too.
乔什也参加了每一次活动。
Thank you, Josh.
谢谢你，乔什。
And she's one of those people.
她就是那种人。
she's just one of those people.
她真的是那种人。
Going back to the scene of you guys playing at the piano, I was just going to say when we're talking about your chemistry, I loved the moment because she is so confident, right?
回到你们在钢琴前弹奏的那场戏，我正想说，当我们谈到你们的化学反应时，我非常喜欢那个时刻，因为她太自信了，对吧？
She is the ringmaster of this, right?
她才是这个局的掌控者，对吧？
She's laid down the rules of this game, we're not going to kiss, we're only going to drum roll, we're not going to tell each other any more information than these first names, which only reluctantly got spilled because of Barney and he's saying Ted 5,000 times, which is so funny.
她定下了这场游戏的规则：我们不接吻，我们只打鼓（指摇滚手势/暗号），我们除了名字之外不会向对方透露任何更多信息，而名字也只是因为巴尼一直在不停地喊“泰德”整整五千遍才勉强说漏嘴的，这太搞笑了。
And also his insistence on saying it over and over.
还有他坚持不懈地一遍又一遍地喊。
Ted, Ted.
泰德，泰德。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
But then there's this moment, the first time you guys almost kissed at that piano, which also it's funny because all of a sudden Ted's great at piano, I don't know if we ever showed Ted being ready to go back to that.
但随后有了这样一个时刻，你们第一次差点在钢琴旁接吻，这也很有趣，因为泰德突然变得擅长弹钢琴了，我不知道我们是否展示过泰德会弹琴这事儿。
Yeah, it was a lot of weird little buys in there.
对，里面有很多奇怪的小巧思。
But that moment where you guys almost kiss and she kind of pulls away, pulls back from fully kissing, And she looks so at that for just one moment, very helpless, very like she's under Ted's thrall there for a minute.
但就在你们几乎要接吻的那一刻，她有点退缩了，没有真正亲下去，仅仅那么一瞬间，她看起来是那么无助，就像是在那一分钟里完全被泰德迷住了。
She's gone a little bit past where she meant to go.
她有点超出她原本的计划了。
And she plays it in this great moment.
她在那个精彩的时刻把这个演得太棒了。
And you realize she's been playing the whole thing so in control up to that moment.
你会发现，直到那一刻之前，她整场戏都掌控得游刃有余。
And then she flips it in that moment.
然后就在那一刻，她来了个大反转。
She shows that she's also vulnerable.
她展露了自己脆弱的一面。
She's not running the signal.
她不是在发信号。
So that was totally the signal.
所以那绝对就是信号。
That was the signal.
那就是信号。
I love how she played that moment.
我太喜欢她处理那个时刻的方式了。
That is like a great acting.
这简直就是神级演技。
I also love, it's kind of like that great thing of like use what's in the room, right?
我也很喜欢，这有点像那种绝佳的技巧：利用房间里现有的东西，对吧？
He's on the piano, but when she says something about not kissing him, he hits all the bass notes.
他在弹钢琴，但当她说起没有吻他的事时，他用力弹了所有的低音。
Yeah, oh my God, that was so funny.
对，哦天哪，太搞笑了。
Yeah, that was such a great moment.
对，那真是个极好的时刻。
Yeah, that was a laugh out loud from my wife Rebecca watching now.
对，我妻子丽贝卡（Rebecca）在看的时候直接笑出声了。
Rebecca loves this two part or two, and I think it was like, this is a good dead one.
丽贝卡很喜欢这上下两集，我觉得当时她就觉得，这集真棒。
You guys are gonna have fun talking about this one.
你们俩聊这一集肯定会聊得很开心。
She laughed out loud at the minor chord in moment there.
她为刚才那个小调和弦的时刻大声笑了出来。
So good.
太棒了。
Alec, let's play Jordana's, this is of course, It's a section where we're calling, questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
亚历克，我们来听听乔丹娜（Jordana）的留言，这当然是这样一个环节：我们邀请了一位临床心理学家的提问和观察，她从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》，而且恰好是乔什的妻子。
I felt like this episode was some sort of turning point in the show for me.
我觉得对这部剧来说，这一集对我而言算是一个某种转折点。
Halfway through I said to Josh, I'm suddenly feeling very attached to these characters.
看到一半的时候，我对乔什说，我突然开始对这些角色产生强烈的羁绊了。
I was laughing harder at the jokes, certain moments were tugging at the heartstrings more deeply.
我对笑话的反应更强烈了，某些时刻也更能触动心弦。
But later I was reflecting on why that might be.
但后来我一直在反思这是为什么。
And I think for me, it's because it's the first episode where Robin showed real vulnerability.
我想对我来说，是因为这是罗宾展现出真实脆弱感的第一集。
It's almost like I couldn't be fully in, I couldn't fully fall for this love story until she did.
就好像在这一刻到来之前，我无法全身心投入，无法真正爱上这个爱情故事。
This is the first time we see her cry.
这是我们第一次看到她哭。
We see that she really feels what Ted is feeling too.
我们看到她也真正感受到了泰德的感受。
And the title Drumroll, please, which we think is about the anticipation between Victoria and Ted, I actually think on a deeper level is about Ted and Robin, and their long, drawn out drumroll and the audience staying in that anticipation with them for many, many years.
而剧名《鼓声响起，请》，我们原本以为是指维多利亚和泰德之间的悬念，但实际上，我觉得在更深的层面上，它是指泰德和罗宾，指他们漫长而拖沓的“鼓声”，以及观众陪伴他们多年共同经历的悬念。
But I'm curious if you also felt like this was some sort of turning point for the show.
不过我很好奇，你们是否也觉得这是该剧的一个转折点。
if you felt like it was this episode that really hooked people.
你们是否觉得正是这一集真正吸引了观众？
And if so, why?
如果是的话，为什么？
That's a great question.
这真是个好问题。
I love that she pointed out the Robin of it all because we haven't talked that much about that.
我很高兴她指出了“罗宾的特质”这一点，因为我们之前没怎么讨论过这个。
It happens later in the episode, but the reveal that Robin went to the wedding and saw Ted and Victoria seemingly kissing.
这发生在剧集的后半部分，但那个揭晓是：罗宾去了婚礼现场，看到了泰德和维多利亚似乎在接吻。
Of course, she didn't know they were gonna pull up at the last minute from actually kissing and then cried in the bathroom.
当然，她并不知道他们在最后一刻忍住没真的吻上去，然后她在洗手间里哭了。
I totally, Jordana, that's a great point because seeing her in tears in that bathroom stall is a huge pivot point for the Robin and Ted of it all, and so many other things.
乔丹娜，我完全赞同，这真是个绝佳的观点，因为看到她在洗手间隔间里泪流满面，对于罗宾和泰德的关系以及许多其他事情来说，是一个巨大的转折点。
It leaves groundwork for so many other things that are gonna happen that season and in the series.
它为这个季度乃至整部剧后续要发生的事情埋下了大量的伏笔。
And it's true, we haven't seen Robin exhibit that amount of vulnerability and feeling, and maybe surprise, it's a great moment because it seems to surprise her too.
确实如此，我们以前没见过罗宾表现出如此程度的脆弱和情感，或许还有惊讶——这是个极好的时刻，因为这似乎也让她自己感到意外。
I think Kobe plays this great thing of like, what's happened?
我觉得寇碧（Cobie）把这个演得太好了，那种：发生了什么？
She's like a robot crying.
她就像一个会哭的机器人。
She's like, what are these crazy?
她好像在说，这些疯狂的是什么？
Why is there water coming out of my eyes?
为什么我的眼里会有水流出来？
And I love that moment too.
我也很喜欢那个时刻。
I think Joanna is very astute to say That was a moment that hooked you in deeper to like the larger Robin and Ted story.
我觉得乔丹娜非常敏锐，她说这是让你更深地被宏大的罗宾和泰德的故事所吸引的时刻。
Yeah.
是的。
It also, I mean, I agree, I could feel when Robin enters, it lifts this from like a charming kind of episode of television to like a real heartfelt episode.
而且，我的意思是，我同意，我能感觉到当罗宾出场时，它把这集从一部迷人的普通电视剧提升到了一部真正感人至深的剧集。
Yes.
是的。
Because it's like- I remember someone in grad school, I think when I was in grad school at NYU that it was something like, we were all standing in a circle and it was like, you're in love with the per, you're facing the back of the print and someone's looking at your back.
因为就像——我记得在读研究生时，我想大约是我在纽约大学读研究生的时候，我们都围成一个圈，就像是，你爱着那个人，你面对着那个人的后背，而另一个人正看着你的后背。
And it was like, you're in love with the person who's back, you're staring at.
就好像，你爱着那个你正凝视着其后背的人。
And it was like, that's every check off play is like everyone's in love with someone who's not in love with them.
这就好像，契诃夫的每一部戏剧都是这样的：每个人都爱着一个不爱自己的人。
And it feels like, you know, the, I think there's a phenomenon that is not coined or I don't know the phrase for it.
而且这感觉就像，你知道，我觉得有一种现象还没有被命名，或者我不知道该怎么称呼它。
But it's when someone knows someone is in love with someone or someone has feelings for it, they're not going to be with the person necessary.
但这种情况就是，当一个人知道另一个人爱着自己或者对自己有好感时，他们其实并不一定要和这个人在一起。
They don't want to maybe be with the person, but they enjoy basking in that affection, that affectionate light.
他们或许不想和这个人在一起，但他们很享受沐浴在那份爱意、那种充满爱意的光芒中的感觉。
And if that person removes that focus and light and shines it elsewhere, that person's like, wait a minute, where did you go.
而如果那个人把注意力和光芒收回并照向别处，那个人就会想，等一下，你去哪了。
So I think there's something interesting about Robin kind of, you know, keeping Ted at arm's length.
所以我觉得罗宾和泰德保持一定距离这件事，挺有意思的。
She's dating other people.
她在和别人约会。
But clearly, she's sitting at that bar at McLarens.
但很明显，她坐在麦克拉伦酒吧里。
She's got to catch him looking over at her.
她一定能察觉到他看着她。
And yes, I'll get you another drink.
而且，“好吧，我再给你拿杯饮料”。
You know, he's got a bit of a, he's really trying to be the guy for her.
你知道，他有点儿……他真的很想成为适合她的那个男人。
And the moment she sees him with a beautiful woman at a wedding that's not her, this rush of like feeling comes out that I think really takes her by surprise.
而当她看到他和另一个美丽的女人在一个不属于她的婚礼上时，那种汹涌的情感喷涌而出，我觉得这真的让她大吃一惊。
And I'm not saying Robin is the type who's like, oh, I just want Ted to be my puppy dog all the time.
我不是说罗宾是那种“哦，我只想让泰德一直当我的小跟班”的人。
I think she really genuinely realizes in that moment, oh, I like, I do like this guy.
我觉得在那一刻她是真心意识到，哦，我喜欢，我确实喜欢这家伙。
I'm terrified of commitment.
我很害怕承诺。
I'm terrified of breaking hearts and getting heartbroken.
我很害怕伤害别人和心碎。
But at the same time, I'm having an emotional response to this and it's really taken me by surprise.
但与此同时，我对这件事产生了情感上的反应，这真的让我大吃一惊。
Yeah.
对。
And I think that sort of power flip in that moment is really interesting in their dynamic right because she she's doing for her a grand romantic gesture her showing up in that dress running there after her like big moment of host you know the anchoring the 11 p.m.
而且我认为那一刻权力的这种反转在他们两个人的动态关系中非常有趣，因为她为他做出了属于她的浪漫壮举——她穿着那件裙子出现，在她经历了一件超级大事——主持晚上11点的新闻之后朝那边跑去，这可是她职业生涯的大事，她一直说事业第一，但她却从那个经历中飞奔出来去追赶泰德，对吧？这是一个巨大的举动，对罗宾来说这就相当于举起了一只蓝色的法国号。
news this is a huge career thing for her she's always said career comes first but she bolts out of that experience to go catch up with Ted right that's that's a huge gesture that's a holding up a blue french horn gesture for Robin and when she gets there and she's she's missed him she's missed someone window of opportunity, she literally sees him moving on from her, like quite literally in real time in front of her eyes.
当她赶到那里却发现她错过了他，错过了某个机会窗口，她眼睁睁地看着他向前看，抛下了她，几乎就是活生生地在她眼前实时发生着。
It really hits her.
这真的触动了她。
这真的深深触动了她。
And Kobe played that so beautifully.
蔻碧把那场戏演得太美妙了。
I do think the bathroom stall scene between the two of them is just a beautiful thing.
我确实觉得他们俩在洗手间隔间的戏简直太美妙了。
I also was like, this episode is smashing the Bechtel test.
我还觉得，这一集简直轻松通过了贝克德尔测试。
Do you know the Bechtel test?
你知道贝克德尔测试吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我愿意。
Yes.
是的。
So it's where you have two female characters, both of whose name the audience knows having a conversation.
所以它要求有两个女性角色，观众知道她们两个的名字，并且她们在进行对话。
Oh, I guess maybe it doesn't because they're talking about.
哦，我猜可能不算，因为她们在谈论……
I was worried.
我当时很担心。
I was wondering why you're going with it because they're talking about a guy.
我在想你为什么选这个，因为她们在谈论一个男人。
They are talking about a guy, but not.
她们确实在谈论一个男人，但不是那样的。
But they're not.
但她们不是。
They're talking around it, right?
她们是在旁敲侧击，对吧？
They're talking around it.
她们是在旁敲侧击。
They're not talking about a guy.
她们不是在谈论一个男人。
She's just trying to comfort her.
她只是在安慰她。
Yeah.
是的。
And Victoria is showing what a good person she is and comforting this woman.
维多利亚展现了她是个多好的人，并在安慰这个女人。
She has no idea what's wrong with Robin.
她根本不知道罗宾怎么了。
And Robin's never realizing shit.
而罗宾一点也没意识到。
Not only is Ted about But to kiss this woman, this woman is really a warm-hearted, caring person, too.
不仅泰德正要吻这个女人，而且这个女人实际上也是一个热心肠、有爱心的人。
Do you know the actress Aya Cash?
你知道女演员阿亚·卡什吗？
No, I've done a bunch of stuff with her.
不知道，我和她合作过很多次。
She's really brilliant and funny.
她真的很才华横溢又幽默。
Her mom is a poet, quite a well-known, well-regarded poet.
她的妈妈是一位诗人，一位相当知名、备受推崇的诗人。
And she has a poem, maybe we could put this poem in this show notes, Alec.
她有一首诗，也许我们可以把这首诗放在本期节目笔记里，亚历克。
It's called, To the Woman Crying Uncontrollably in the Stahl Next to Me.
它叫《致隔壁隔间里痛哭流涕的女人》。
Oh, man, I think I've read this poem.
天哪，我想我读过这首诗。
Yeah.
是的。
it's almost the exact premise, just like, you know, it's a little pep talk to a woman crying in the stall.
这几乎就是那个设定，就好像，你知道的，对一个在隔间里哭泣的女人进行的一点鼓舞。
But I don't know, I mean, do they talk necessarily about Ted?
但我不晓得，我是说，他们一定会聊到泰德吗？
I think it's more like, I don't know.
我觉得更像是，我不知道。
I think they don't tell.
我觉得他们没说。
It's just the moment.
这只是那一刻。
Yeah, they're not just the moment Ted.
对，他们不只是为了泰德那一刻。
Yeah, no, it's a nice moment.
对，不，那是个美好的时刻。
That's that, and they never see each other and she just sees the shoes.
事情就是这样，他们再也没见过面，而她只看到了鞋子。
In fact, I have a problem.
其实，我遇到个问题。
I'm hanging on one second, I never brought.
我等一下，我从来没带过。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
We're watching it and we see, and I was like, I love that thing where you just see your shoes and Rebecca, my wife gets up and walks into her, into the bedroom to her jewelry thing and comes back and holds up this, which is exactly what was on the snowflake from Victoria's shoes.
我们在看的时候看到了，然后我说，我超喜欢那种你只能看到鞋子的镜头，然后我老婆丽贝卡起身走到卧室里的首饰盒旁，回来拿起了这个，这跟维多利亚鞋子上的雪花一模一样。
I was like, how do you have that?
我当时就问：你怎么会有这个？
She's like, you're costume designer.
她说：你服装设计师。
I was like complimenting it during that shoot day and they were like, well, we're done with it.
我说我那场拍摄日一直在夸它，然后他们说，反正拍完了。
It's all shot.
全都拍完了。
Why don't you take this?
你干嘛不拿走？
So she has this as like a little pendant.
所以她就把这个当成一个小吊坠留着。
So I have this little snowflake from a Victoria's shoe that you see on that.
所以我手里有维多利亚鞋子上那个雪花的小挂件，也就是你在画面里看到的那个。
It's a great moment when Barney's like, he's dude, he's not gonna know what kind of shoe she.
当巴尼说：老兄，他根本不知道她是什么鞋的时候，那真是一个绝佳的时刻。
But it's also like, it's not because Ted is like into female shoes.
但这也是因为，并不是说泰德对女人的鞋有多痴迷。
He literally handed them to him.
是他亲手递给他的。
Yeah.
对。
There was no fetish required there.
这里面可没什么恋物癖。
Yeah.
对。
But yeah, it's a great.
不过，这真的很棒。
It's all a mystery.
这全都是谜团。
It's all clues, right?
全都是线索，对吧？
It's all a mystery and clues.
这全都是谜团和线索。
Robin has to fill in this other part of the mystery.
罗宾必须去拼凑谜团的另一部分。
We had no idea.
我们根本不知道。
Robin was even there, but she's the door to the final, the final port of the video game.
罗宾当时也在场，但她就像是通往终点的门，电子游戏的最终关卡。
like Ted will sacrifice his own needs and wants to make Robin happy.
就像泰德会牺牲自己的需求和愿望来让罗宾开心。
I don't think she actually does it, but she is right about to say, I know who this woman is and I can tell you where.
我觉得她其实没说出口，但她当时正准备说：我知道这个女人是谁，我能告诉你她在哪里。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like, yeah, she knew she was the baker, right?
就像，对，她知道她是个面包师，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
So she was going to put Ted's desires and happiness above her own.
所以她打算把泰德的愿望和幸福置于她自己之上。
The same way that Ted has done that repeatedly so far in the show.
就像泰德在这部剧里之前屡次做过的那样。
it's so bittersweet and yet sweet and it's it's it's really nice.
这真是苦乐参半，却又分外甜蜜，真的非常美好。
I like not knowing what she's going to say to Ted when she's like going out of the bar.
我喜欢她走出酒吧时那种不知道她会对泰德说什么的悬念。
It's great suspense which way she's going to go with it.
这种悬念感太棒了，不知道她最终会作何选择。
Louie trying to push her towards Ted, Roman ultimately doing the right thing or what she thinks is the right thing.
莉莉试图把她推向泰德，罗宾最终还是做了正确的事，或者她认为正确的事。
Trying to do what's best for Ted because Roman knows she's you know she's still Robin.
努力去做对泰德最好的事，因为罗宾知道，你知道的，她依然是罗宾。
She's still confused.
她依然很纠结。
Yeah.
对。
I had a couple of other observations and things I loved about about the episode.
我还有几个其他的观察，以及我超喜欢这一集的一些地方。
Can I just run through them?
能让我连珠炮似地说一下吗？
Yeah, ma'am.
行，请吧。
Was that a picture of Gloria Calderon-Callet?
那张照片是格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆-凯利吗？
That was, oh, I wanted to call everybody.
那是，哦，我想给每个人打电话。
That was a picture of a whole bunch of people, including me and Rebecca.
那是很多人的合影，包括我和丽贝卡。
You catch that one?
你注意到那个了吗？
Yeah, that's me and her.
对，那是我和她。
That's my wedding picture.
那是我的结婚照。
I know, it sort of goes by and you're like, oh, it's stock photos, you're bringing those to sleep for a second, but no, those are almost all, I don't remember every single one of them, but mostly how much a mother establishes Michael Shea in his wife.
我知道，画面一闪而过，你会觉得，哦，这是素材照片，你会愣上一秒钟，但其实，几乎全都是——我不记得每一个了，但主要有迈克尔·谢伊和他妻子的。
You see Stu Halpern's husband Adam is there at their wedding and Stu is our post-producer.
你可以看到斯图·哈尔珀恩的丈夫亚当也在他们的婚礼上，斯图是我们的后期制片人。
Myself and Rebecca are our wedding photo, one of our wedding photos is there, and God, there's a couple others that I'm not feeling bad that I'm playing anywhere.
还有我和丽贝卡的结婚照，我们的结婚照之一也在那儿，天哪，还有其他好几张，虽然我现在记不太清了，但也没什么好遗憾的。
But Gloria and Dave, Gloria and her husband, Dave, are really great at the writer of this episode who did a great job in this episode.
不过格洛丽亚和戴夫，格洛丽亚和她丈夫戴夫真的很棒，本集的编剧在这集里表现得非常出色。
Yeah, that was really fun.
对，真的很有趣。
Yeah.
对。
It's fun when you're in the show.
能出现在剧里感觉很有趣。
Like, I think part of the Cirque, remember I said the Cirque and the Riff?
就像，我认为马戏团和即兴段子的一部分，还记得我说过马戏团和即兴段子吗？
The Cirque and the Riff.
马戏团和即兴段子。
I was thinking about the Cirque and the Riff.
我当时就在想马戏团和即兴段子。
The surf is there's a shot of the surf in like the first episode like like there's a series of photographs I think the surf made an agreement But I notice this thing Well, I like it when when you're doing a show and you can actually put things in that are just literally Easter eggs for you They're there for no one else.
马戏拍的是，比如第一集里有个冲浪镜头的特写，就像是一系列照片，我觉得冲浪达成了一种默契，但我注意到这件事，好吧，我喜欢那种你在拍剧时，可以真正塞进一些纯粹属于你的彩蛋，它们不是为了别人而存在。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, totally for the friend who gets to be in a movie or a TV show I liked when I think it's Lily who said like come on.
对，完全是给那些有机会客串电影或电视剧的朋友准备的。我喜欢——我觉得是莉莉说的——拜托。
It's for a good cause or they're talking to Barney like call her, like it's for a good cause.
为了一个崇高的事业，或者他们劝巴尼给那个女孩打电话时说，为了一个崇高的事业。
Yeah.
对。
And there's something about Lillie and Marshall, especially like getting Ted paired off is like part of their life's work.
莉莉和马歇尔之间有些互动，尤其是帮泰德牵线搭桥，感觉就像是他们毕生的事业。
Like this is like, this is part of their like sacred duty on the earth.
就像这是，这是他们在世时的神圣职责。
Like we gotta get to that front porch.
就像我们必须坐上那个前廊。
Like with a person with a woman we like and this is very important for all of us.
和我们喜欢的人在一起，这对我们所有人都非常重要。
Yes.
没错。
It's like this fact project.
就像这个团队项目。
They're all in on it.
他们全都参与其中。
It's a group project.
这绝对是个团队项目。
It totally is.
完全就是。
And Lillie's like the leader of that project.
而莉莉就像是这个项目的组长。
Yes.
没错。
Marshall just wants to know who made that cake, which I love to play as sort of a very stupid little runner, but actually is the actual piece of information.
马歇尔只想知道是谁做的那个蛋糕，我超喜欢这个设定，虽然看起来像个很蠢的小插曲，但实际上这才是真正的关键信息。
But it seems like such a stupid thing that he's just a guy who wants to eat this delicious cake.
但这听起来像是一件极其蠢的事，他居然只是个想吃这个美味蛋糕的家伙。
And I love how like religiously devoted he's become to this cake.
我特别喜欢他对这个蛋糕那种狂热般的执着。
But in the end, it actually is a huge plot point.
但到头来，这居然成了个巨大的剧情转折。
It's like the one and only plot point of the whole episode.
这简直可以说是整集里唯一的一个剧情转折。
And the fact that she's the one who made that cake even recruits him more, like we have to go find this woman.
而她恰好是做那个蛋糕的人，这就更让他坚定了信念：我们必须找到这个女人。
You've got to marry this is the one, yes.
你必须娶她，就是她了，没错。
I'll eat this cake forever on that front porch if we just marry her.
只要我们娶了她，我以后要在那个前廊上永远吃这个蛋糕。
another martial line I loved or Ichter.
另一个我超喜欢的马歇尔台词，或者说是……
It's probably not Ichter.
可能不是这个。
That made me laugh out.
那句话把我逗笑了。
That was the last all that moment.
那是那个时刻的全部。
This episode has a lot of good moments.
这一集有很多精彩时刻。
This is a lot of good moments in this episode.
这一集里有好多好玩的瞬间。
The wedding gets a little shorter shift because it's kind of like, it's the drum roll up to drum roll, please.
婚礼那部分被稍微压缩了一点，因为它有点像是为“敲击鼓点”做铺垫。
That of the free, you know, it's sort of the work you have to do to then like have the fun part of the roller coaster ride, which is this one.
就是那种为了迎来过山车最刺激的部分（也就是这一集）而必须做前的铺垫。
But boy, as an hour, what a good one.
但是天哪，作为一个小时的节目，这一集真的太棒了。
The wedding has more narrative propulsion in a weird way.
从某种奇怪的角度来看，婚礼情节的叙事推进力更强。
Yeah, well, there's a huge.
对，呃，这里面有很大的……
Like the wedding is like, it just goes.
就像婚礼那集，它就是一直在往前走。
It has an accelerated kind of thing.
它有一种加速前进的感觉。
And drum roll has a little more of a like, well, let's stop rowing here and sit on the side of the river for a minute and say something funny and then get back in.
而“击鼓传花”那集则更像是，好吧，我们现在在河边停一会儿，在河岸上坐上一分钟，讲个好笑的笑话，然后再上船。
But there's something also about morning afters that always have like some really funny stuff in the show.
但关于宿醉清晨的戏份也总是很有意思，剧里总能搞出一些非常好笑的东西。
Yeah, and constructing the mystery of what happened.
对，而且还要构建究竟发生了什么这种悬念。
Yeah, I love that.
对，我太喜欢这个了。
We talked about this in the last episode, but Lily saying happiness is not that difficult, which we both agreed is both smart and sensible and also a little bit young because it is.
我们在上一集聊过这个，但莉莉说“幸福没那么难”，我们俩都觉得这句话既聪明又通情达理，但同时也显得有点年轻，因为确实如此。
It's really young.
真的很年轻。
Yeah, it is.
对，确实是。
And they hit their own rapids up ahead, you know?
而且他们前面也会遇到自己的激流险滩，对吧？
They do more than a few times.
他们遇到了不止好几次。
Yeah, I really like that because I like that we showed a couple that actually loves each other and they're not like the bickersons as they say.
对，我真的很喜欢这一点，因为我喜欢我们展现了一对真正相爱的情侣，他们不是那种人们常说的爱吵嘴的人。
They're not like the TV couple, it's always fighting which is a real trope on TV, especially at the time when the show premiered, there was a lot of those.
他们不像是那种总是在争吵的电视情侣，这是电视上的一个老套路了，特别是这部剧刚开播的那个时期，有海量这种设定。
And I'm proud that we didn't do that, but I'm also proud that we showed that a couple that young might, they might think they've got it all figured out.
我很骄傲我们没有走那条老路，但我也很骄傲我们展示了这么年轻的一对情侣，他们可能会觉得自己什么都懂了。
But if you keep watching, you won't let them go.
但如果你继续看下去，你就不会放过他们。
You're gonna go do some shit too.
你们也会去经历一些狗血的事情的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
It will find us all.
这一切终究会落到我们每个人头上。
Another Alison Hannigan moment that I really loved when she finally gets Robin to admit she has feelings for Ted.
另一个我很喜欢的艾丽森·汉妮根的高光时刻，是她终于让罗宾承认自己对泰德有感觉。
And I think Robin says, do you have, you know, and now he just says a little.
然后我想罗宾说的是，你有，你知道的，现在他只说了一点点。
Yeah.
对。
A little.
一点点。
Yeah.
对。
What is it that she's doing in that moment that's so magical?
她在那个时刻做的究竟是什么，能那么有魔力？
I, I, that's one of those moments for me too.
我，我，对我来说这也是那种高光时刻之一。
There's something you can't teach that in acting, right?
有些东西是演技教不出来的，对吧？
That's like, no, she has a bunch of those in season one, which are just like, they're just little adorable throwaways that couldn't be better.
就像是，不，她在第一季里有很多这样的表现，就像是那些可爱的小随笔，简直不能再棒了。
Like she, they just couldn't be better than no one else could do it exactly the way she did it.
就像她，真的不能再棒了，换作别人绝对无法像她那样完美地演绎出来。
I don't know what it is.
我不知道那到底是什么。
That is, that is the, the ineffable, the ineffable thing.
那就是，那就是那种妙不可言、只可意会的东西。
The thing that is just, you can't put your finger on, it's just magic, it's, yeah, all of you guys.
那种你无法确切指出是什么的东西，简直就是魔法，对，你们所有人。
I love all of you guys.
我爱你们所有人。
When does Marshall say, baby, what are you talking about?
玛修什么时候说过，“宝贝，你在说什么呢？”
Like he said it like really in a.
他当时说得就像是真的很……
Yeah, he screams at like a crazy person.
对，他像个疯子一样大喊大叫。
It's when he thinks they're gonna not go try to find.
那是当他以为他们不打算去试着找……的时候。
The cake.
蛋糕。
Victoria, yeah, because he wants to find the cake.
维多利亚，对，因为他想找到那个蛋糕。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
He's angry that he thinks they're not gonna go.
他很生气，因为他以为他们不打算去了。
That was one of those Jason lines that on the page, I don't think it was.
那是杰森的台词之一，在剧本纸面上，我觉得它并不像那样。
Doesn't play like a joke really.
读起来其实并不像个笑话。
You know, but it plays like he just did it like, like he's in a Scorsese, he's just so much passion.
你知道的，但他的演绎方式就像，就像他在拍马丁·斯科塞斯的电影一样，充满了激情。
A thousand percent commitment.
百分之千的投入。
Yeah.
对。
I like to test in the middle of a big speech and Barney goes, I crapper get off the pot.
我喜欢在一段精彩演讲中间，巴尼说：“要么拉屎，要么占着茅坑别拉。”
I'm sorry.
不好意思。
Yeah.
对。
That was great.
太棒了。
We'll get to that in a second.
我们一会儿再谈那个。
But one of my other favorite, this is one of my favorite Ted lines and it's a real throw away.
但这是我最喜欢的泰德台词之一，虽然是一句随口说出的话。
You have to listen for it of season one.
你得在第一季里仔细听。
I've been busting my Apple bag all week.
我一整周都在拼命工作。
I'm so glad you brought this up.
我很高兴你提起这个。
I was afraid I was gonna forget to mention that one.
我刚才还担心我会忘了提那个呢。
I love it.
我太喜欢了。
It's like Hot Top, bro.
就像是“Hot Top”一样，兄弟。
Like it's just, I don't know why it just delights me.
就好像是，我不知道为什么它就是让我开心。
You know what, it's not a phrase that's like was in the culture at that time.
你知道吗，这不是当时流行文化里有的短语。
No, it was in the culture in 1850.
不，那是1850年流行文化里的。
He says it like, I don't know, it sounds like newsies or something.
他说这句话的语气，我不知道，听起来像是报童什么的。
I have this memory that that was one of our writers, Chris Marshall.
我记得那是我们的编剧之一，克里斯·马歇尔。
Oh, of course, wait, was he the one who wore the pork by hat or the other one?
哦，当然，等等，他是那个戴着猪肉派帽的人还是另一个人？
Yeah, he did.
对，他是。
He sort of felt old, tiny in his way, Chris Marcel, and I think he would enjoy that characterization because he, that was his style.
克里斯·马歇尔在某种程度上给人一种老派的感觉，我想他会喜欢这种评价，因为那就是他的风格。
He always wore like these suits and like had like, yeah, vests, and he looked sort of like a Southern gentleman en route to the Kentucky Derby.
他总是穿那种西装，还带着，对，马甲，他看起来有点像个在去肯塔基德比路上的南方绅士。
And his writing partner looked like a writer in Hollywood.
而他的搭档看起来就像个好莱坞的编剧。
Yeah, just a writer in Hollywood.
对，就是一个好莱坞编剧。
Just like a dude.
就像个普通老兄。
Yeah.
对。
And they were a great duo, really funny dudes.
他们是一对绝佳的搭档，非常搞笑的家伙。
I think they're right on what we do in shadows now.
我想他们现在正在参与《吸血鬼生活》的编剧。
They're really good writers.
他们真的是很好的编剧。
I like we got to do the like the full alumni list of like these are the other things all the how much mother writers did We're so proud of how I'm how amazing the combined credits all are but they're really funny I've had this feeling like that was from crisp because he sort of exists In an earlier era he sort of exists and he's sort of just threw that out there Everyone the version was like what the fuck is that phrase?
我喜欢我们做了一个完整的校友名单，上面列出了其他所有作家所做的事情，我们为所有这些组合演职员表感到非常自豪，但它们真的很好笑，我有一种感觉，这好像是克里斯想的，因为他生活在一个更早的时代，他好像就那么随口一说，每个人都觉得那是什么鬼词组？
I never said that and It's we were just like let's put it in there.
我从来没说过，我们当时就是想，把它放进去吧。
Let's see if we can bring it back I don't think we ever bought it back.
看看我们能不能让它流行回来，我觉得我们大概没能让它流行回来。
I like how it's said by Ted in a very, like, it's like I say this all the time.
我喜欢泰德说这句话时的语气，就好像我经常这么说一样。
Like, yeah, last week you were busting my apple bag?
就像是，对啊，上周你还在烦我？
This week you're busting my apple bag?
这周你又来烦我？
Like, it's really funny and silly.
真的很好笑也很蠢。
You say it, you played it in the best way where you call no attention to it and there by like, it made it 10 times better.
你说得很好，你用了一种完全不引人注目的方式来处理它，因此它变得好笑了一百倍。
It's great.
太棒了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Just going back to that idea that Victoria had about preserving the perfection of it by not allowing it to get solid by the later time.
回到维多利亚刚才那个想法，通过不允许它被后来的时间所玷污来保持它的完美。
I don't know, I always, I hate repeating myself and if I ever do gentle listeners, just forgive me.
我不知道，我一直，我讨厌重复自己，如果我真的说了，温和的听众们，请原谅我。
But Richard Rohr, who's a Franciscan priest that I love, he has this thing about perfection that he says that I think is so smart.
但是理查德·罗尔，一个我非常喜欢的方济各会神父，他对完美有一个观点，我觉得非常精辟。
He says, human perfection excludes imperfection.
他说，人类的完美排斥不完美。
Divine perfection includes imperfection.
神圣的完美包含不完美。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't think you've ever said that.
我觉得你从没说过这个。
I don't care.
我不在乎。
I need to say that anymore.
我不需要再说了。
And if you did, it's a wonderful imperfection.
如果你说过了，这也是一种美妙的不完美。
Right.
没错。
You're repeating it.
你在重复它。
Yes, exactly.
对，没错。
But no, we, as humans, we want to, we want, we think perfection is like keep that imperfection out.
但不是的，作为人类，我们想要，我们想，我们认为完美就是把那些不完美排除在外。
But in the grand sense of things, imperfections included, he has a book called Everything Belongs.
从宏观角度来看，包括不完美在内，他有一本书叫《万物皆有归属》。
Right?
对吧？
Yeah.
对。
So I think in, in, when you look at the, I think that's what a lot of people are saying when when they write in and leave us voice notes about how I meant it.
所以我觉得，当你看到……我觉得很多人写信给我们，或者留下语音留言说他们对《老爸老妈浪漫史》的看法时，表达的正是这个意思。
And mother is like, it kept them going because you see the imperfection in the struggle.
母亲就像是……它支撑着他们走下去，因为你在挣扎中看到了不完美。
Why is this happening?
为什么会这样？
This shouldn't be happening this way.
事情不该是这样的。
But you see that it was all leading somewhere.
但你发现这一切其实都是命中注定的指引。
It's mostly about imperfection.
这主要关于不完美。
Yeah, it's mostly about imperfection.
对，主要关于不完美。
But it also says that that imperfection not contrary to the idea that it means the universe is chaotic and disordered.
但它也说明，这种不完美并不意味着宇宙是混乱和无序的。
It actually says, no, in spite, no, because of that, and because of the long tail of looking at things with some perspective, you see the universe is benevolent and ordered.
它实际上在说，不，正相反，恰恰相反，而且从长远和某种宏观视角来看，你会发现宇宙其实是充满善意且有序的。
Yes, I totally agree.
是的，我完全同意。
And I think literally we manifested it, whether we meant to or not, when Ted shows up in this completely imperfect outfit with bleach stains, right, they meet in tuxedos and they meet and he's a knight in shining armor, and she's the princess in the tower.
而且我觉得，无论我们是否有意，我们确实让它成真了：当泰德穿着这身完全不完美、带着漂白剂渍的衣服出现时，对吧，他们在一群穿燕尾服的人中间相遇，他就像穿着闪亮盔甲的骑士，而她是高塔里的公主。
And he goes in and she's covered in flour, putting frosting on cupcakes and he's wearing a shirt with stands on it.
他走进去时，她身上沾满了面粉，正在给纸杯蛋糕抹糖霜，而他穿着一件有污渍的衬衫。
And that's why I think that moment gets me so much when she says, oh, thank God.
这就是为什么我觉得那一刻深深打动了我，当她说，哦，谢天谢地。
Cause she's kind of like, here's the real me.
因为她有点像是，这才是真实的我。
I'm willing to roll the dice on this being imperfect.
我愿意为这种不完美去冒险。
Look at, just look at me.
看，看着我。
And she's not in a perfect moment either.
而且她当时也不是处于一个完美的时刻。
And they realize they're going to like, they're going to exist in imperfection together.
然后他们意识到，他们将要……他们将要在不完美中一起生活。
They're gonna come, they're gonna risk stepping out of that one little night they were trying to put in like a little hot house.
他们要来，他们要冒险走出那个他们试图小心翼翼呵护在温室里的小小的夜晚。
And even this is like garment as metaphor for the whole episode, like a bleach stain sweatshirt is that thing in an object, right?
甚至连这件衣服都成了整集剧的隐喻，比如一件有漂白剂渍的卫衣，它就是这样一个具体的物件，对吧？
It is like you are more attached to that sweatshirt once it has the bleach stain on it.
一旦那件卫衣有了漂白剂渍，你反而会对它更有感情。
It becomes somehow more perfect with its flaw, right?
它带着瑕疵，却反而变得更加完美了，对吧？
And it becomes more, it's like, it's your, it's a sign of your own humanity in your own imperfection.
而且它变得更……这就像是你自身的人性以及不完美的象征。
I also, it mirrors, it kind of rhymes with him in the pilot going with all of them to go get Robin.
我也觉得，这跟试播集中他和所有人一起去接罗宾的场景有点呼应，异曲同工。
They're all in the taxi.
他们都在出租车里。
Rebecca was like, they always go everywhere and with Ted and in a taxi together.
莉莉当时就说，他们总是和泰德一起坐出租车去任何地方。
They're wildly co-dependent and enmeshed.
他们有着疯狂的共生关系，紧密纠缠在一起。
It's lovely though, it's so funny.
不过这很可爱，太搞笑了。
No, it's adorable.
不，这太讨人喜欢了。
But there's something, you know, And then his, I don't know, like that speech is so lovely, but I mean Barney's, you know, crapper get off the pot is such a good treacle cutter.
但有某种……你知道的，然后他的……我不知道，那段演讲太美好了，不过我是说巴尼的“要么干脆点，要么拉倒”真是个很好的清醒剂。
That is the definition of a good treacle cutter.
那绝对是一个优质清醒剂的定义。
That's it, that's it, right there.
就是这样，就是这样，当场见效。
Yeah.
对。
But I remember, and maybe this is like Ashley just made me as an actor feel so good, but like, there's something about watching me all these years later.
但我记得——也许这只是阿什莉让我作为演员感觉太棒了——多年后回看这一集，还是有些特别的感觉。
I remember seeing this episode and I really liked just how I went and got her.
我记得看这一集时，我真的很喜欢我是怎么去把她找回来的。
You know, there's something so satisfying about his masculine energy that is just forward.
你知道的，他那种勇往直前的男性魅力有一种极其强烈的满足感。
It's like he's in hair.
就像他在弄发型。
He's like Han Solo in this one.
他在这集里就像韩·索罗。
He's Luke Skywalker most of the time.
他平时大部分时间都是卢克·天行者。
He's Han Solo in this one.
但他在这集里是韩·索罗。
Yeah, and there's something great about when Ted, like, crabs are getting off the pot.
对，当泰德“要么干脆点，要么拉倒”的时候，有一种很棒的感觉。
Like, when he's in decision, when he's out of his overthinky indecisive, when he's actually in action, He's an incredibly appealing guy.
就像当他不再优柔寡断、不再过度思考，而是真正付诸行动时，他是一个极具吸引力的家伙。
And you can understand why he would know 83% of the time what to say to a woman.
你能理解为什么他有83%的把握知道该对女人说些什么。
Yeah, yeah, totally.
对，对，完全如此。
And I think that it's one of the most comfortable I've seen you in an episode.
而且我觉得这是我在一集里看到你最自然的状态之一。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
You just seemed very comfortable in this one.
你在这集里显得非常松弛。
Like I don't know, I think you and Ashley just, there was an energy that had unlocked that was like a little different in you in this one.
我不知道，我觉得你和阿什莉之间，有一种被彻底激活的能量，让你在这集里展现出了一点点不同。
And it's just, it's so lovely.
真的非常美好。
And Ted, if you think about it, it's the embodiment of what you always say about Ted, which is like the resilience is sort of the spirit animal of Ted.
如果你仔细想想，泰德就是你经常提到的那种特质的化身，那就是“韧性”可以说是泰德的精神图腾。
He just got so fucked up in the previous episode by how hard he tried to get Robin to me his date to the sweating.
他在上一集里因为拼命想让罗宾做他的舞伴而弄得大汗淋漓、狼狈不堪。
And kind of in the blink of an eye, he is able to scrape himself up from that defeat and be so present and kind of swagger into this new challenge and this new chapter.
而转眼之间，他就能从那次失败中重新振作起来，如此专注地活在当下，带着自信的大摇大摆迎接这个新的挑战和新的篇章。
And I think you played it so great.
我觉得你演得太棒了。
I just think you owned the sort of like the relief of moving on to something new for Ted.
我真的觉得你完美诠释了泰德迈向新生活的释然。
Yeah, but it's funny, you know, Barney's vision for their night was like, we're both gonna like get these bridesmaids and Ted's like, no, I'm actually gonna get a new girlfriend.
对，但很有趣，你知道的，巴尼对他们那个夜晚的设想是，我们俩都要去泡到这些伴娘，而泰德却说，不，其实我要去找个新女朋友。
Yeah.
对。
I'm gonna have a very serious relationship that's gonna start tonight.
我要开始一段非常认真的关系，今晚就开始。
Starts right now.
现在就开始。
This is how we like to end these episodes.
这就是我们喜欢结束这些单集的方式。
We get so many wonderful letters filled with Um, just so much love and gratitude and appreciation and insight and, uh, we're moved every single week by these, uh, keep in common.
我们收到了那么多充满爱意、感激、欣赏和深刻见解的精彩来信，呃，每一周我们都被这些信件深深触动，请大家继续发信来。
Uh, you can go to how we made your mother.com and go to contact and you can either leave us, uh, a voice note or, uh, write something and hopefully it'll make it onto the air.
呃，你可以访问 how we made your mother.com，点击“联系我们”，你可以给我们留一条语音留言，或者写点什么，希望它能被节目播出。
We really, this is a really fun part of this for us is to hear from you guys.
听到你们的声音对我们来说真的是一件非常有趣的事。
So it's a gift.
所以这是一个礼物。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
Keep a comment.
请继续发信。
That's only dear him.
那是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝。
This is the story of how I met you.
这是我如何遇见你的故事。
It's 2011.
那是2011年。
I'm 18 fresh off the train from a small town in India, wide eyed and overwhelmed in Mumbai.
我18岁，刚从印度一个小镇坐火车出来，在孟买睁大双眼，感到不知所措。
For context, it's like moving from a small town to New York.
打个比方，这就像从一个小镇搬到纽约。
Everything was new, fast and exciting.
一切都是崭新的、快节奏的，令人兴奋。
Soon enough, a girl I was very much interested in introduced me to how I met your mother.
很快，一个我很感兴趣的女孩把我带入了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的世界。
It was a funny accident.
这是一个搞笑的意外。
We were at lunch when she took a sip of piping hot soup, winced and yelled, ouchy in my mouth.
我们在吃午饭时，她喝了一口滚烫的汤，龇牙咧嘴地大喊：“好烫，烫到我嘴了！”
And burst out laughing.
然后放声大笑。
I had no idea what she was talking about.
我当时完全不知道她在说什么。
After an enthusiastic 15 minute sales pitch from her and a quick 10 minute hard drive transfer, I hit play on the pilot.
在她热情洋溢地推销了15分钟并快速传输了10分钟的硬盘后，我按下了试播集的播放键。
Little did I know that this 720 P file from a world I had no context for would change my life or as Barney would put it, it taught me how to live.
我当时万万没有想到，这个来自一个我毫无概念的世界的720P视频文件会改变我的人生，或者用巴尼的话说，它教会了我如何生活。
At the time, my English wasn't great.
当时我的英语并不是很好。
I could barely string two proper sentences together.
我甚至很难完整地说出两个像样的句子。
So the first thing I picked up from him, yum, was the language, but what kept me hooked was the world Carter, Craig, and Pam had built.
所以我从他身上学到的第一件事，就是“yum”（真香/好吃），这是语言，但真正让我着迷的是卡特、克雷格和帕姆构建的那个世界。
The way Ted saw his life as a story in the making, that shaped me, his nostalgia, his deep reflections, and future Ted's narration.
泰德将自己的人生视作一个正在进行中的故事的那种视角塑造了我，他的怀旧、他的深沉反思，以及未来泰德的旁白。
It all stayed with me.
这一切都留在了我心里。
Now, when I'm with my friends or caught in an interesting moment, I remind myself that a couple years down the line, this will be a wonderful memory.
现在，每当我跟朋友在一起，或者陷入某个有趣的时刻时，我都会提醒自己，几年之后，这将是一段美好的回忆。
And when it comes back unannounced, it'll make me smile.
而当它不期而至地浮现时，会让我会心一笑。
Ted's words have broken my heart, made me laugh.
泰德的话曾让我心碎，也让我大笑。
And now, after seeing just a little more of life, they feel more real than ever.
而现在，在经历更多的人生之后，这些话感觉比以往任何时候都更加真实。
Sometimes it's like he's talking about me.
有时候感觉他就像是在谈论我。
And then of course, there's the writing, the brilliance of it all.
当然，还有剧本创作，那种无与伦比的才华。
The things himium introduced, the playbook, the bro code, the drum roll, future Ted, future Marshall, you gave me a whole new vocabulary that was funny, fresh, and profound at the same time.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》引入的那些概念：把妹手册、兄弟准则、鼓点、未来泰德、未来马歇尔，你们赋予了我一整套既有趣、新鲜又深奥的新词汇。
I may or may not have stolen life lessons from the show and pass them off as my own wisdom to friends in need.
我可能曾从这部剧里偷师过一些生活经验，并把它们当作自己的大道理传授给需要帮助的朋友。
Let's call it borrowing.
我们姑且称之为“借用”吧。
Now at 29 as a filmmaker, I find myself going back to the show, not just for comfort, but for lessons.
如今29岁的我成了一名电影制作人，我发现自己会不断重温这部剧，不仅是为了寻求慰藉，更是为了学习。
The way you took eccentric, lovable characters and pushed them into raw, vulnerable moments, it's magic.
你们将那些古怪可爱的人物推入真实而脆弱的时刻，这种处理方式简直是魔法。
And somehow, even after a dozen rewatches and knowing every episode inside out, I still discover new details, a subtle reaction, a cool edit call, a background character doing something hilarious.
不知为何，即使在刷了十多遍、对每一集都了如指掌之后，我依然能发现新的细节：一个微妙的反应、一个精彩的剪辑点、背景角色做出的某个搞笑动作。
It's like a little, whoa, that was a cool moment that I enjoyed by myself.
这就像是一个小小的惊喜：“哇，刚才那个瞬间真棒，只有我一个人发现了。”
Also watching the bloopers and 20 things you missed in hymnium videos is still one of my favorite things to do.
此外，看花絮以及“你错过了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的20个细节”之类的视频，依然是我最喜欢做的事情之一。
So to everyone who worked on the show, thank you for the laughs, the heartbreaks, the ridiculous inside jokes, and the life lessons I never saw coming.
所以对于所有为这部剧付出过努力的人，谢谢你们带给我的欢笑、心碎、那些荒谬的内部笑话，以及我始料未及的人生教训。
You had no idea you were shaping a kid in India, one episode at a time, but you did, with all my heart, Hardik, Sajwani.
你们当时绝不会想到，你们正潜移默化地塑造着印度的一个孩子，一集接一集，但你们确实做到了，发自内心地，Hardik，Sajwani。
Oh my gosh, beautiful, wow.
噢天哪，太美妙了，哇。
Beautiful.
太美妙了。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你读这段留言。
Thank you for sharing that story.
谢谢你分享这个故事。
And boy, is your English good now.
而且天哪，你现在的英语说得真好。
See what good teachers you were.
看看你们是多么优秀的老师。
That's incredibly well written.
这写得真是难以置信地好。
That's so good.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, I mean, two things that came up.
对，我是说，有两件事浮现在我脑海。
One is, you know, I'd mentioned this before, but like the world of stage 22 on the Fox lot, all those years was so insulated.
一个是，你知道的，我之前提到过，福克斯片场22号摄影棚的世界，这些年来一直是那么与世隔绝。
And it felt, you know, it's a huge stage, but it felt very small.
而且你会觉得，你知道的，那是个很大的摄影棚，但感觉非常小。
It felt like this little village, this little bustling village with all sorts of, you know, craftspeople and crew members and writers and actors and just everyone milling about making this show.
感觉就像一个小村庄，一个小而热闹的村庄，里面有各种各样的人，你知道的，工匠、剧组人员、编剧、演员，还有所有人都在四处走动，制作这部剧。
And it felt so small, you forget, it was being beamed all over the world.
而且它感觉那么小，以至于你都会忘记，它正在向全世界播送。
Yeah.
对。
All over the world.
全世界。
2011, it was still on, you know, when he got ahold of it.
2011年，当他接触到这部剧的时候，它还在热播。
But it was affecting people's lexicons.
但它正在影响人们的词汇量。
It was affecting people, changing people's sense of humor.
它在影响人们，改变人们的幽默感。
And I've also heard from so many people, I mean, so many people who say, how I met your mother, that's how I learned English.
而且我也听很多人说过，我是说有太多人说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》，那就是我学英语的方式。
I've heard it over and over again, and it floors me equally every time.
我听过无数次了，每次听到我都同样感到震惊。
It hasn't, the amazement has not diminished every time in here that it's, what an honor.
这种惊叹并没有减少，每次听到时都觉得，这真是无上的荣誉。
And it's like, we weren't writing this, thinking people would be learning English from it.
这就好像，我们当初写剧本时，可没想过人们会通过它来学英语。
It's just like, it's so not a consequence we imagined would come of this, because it just can't, too many ripples.
这根本不是我们想象中会带来的结果，因为这不可能预料到，产生的涟漪实在太多了。
It's probably, they say that if you can, the true test of whether you really understand a different language, if you can watch a comedy in that language and laugh and get the jokes, because so much of humor is misdirection or irony.
可能就像他们说的，如果你能——检验你是否真正理解一门不同语言的真正标准，就是看你能不能用那门语言看喜剧并笑出来、听懂笑话，因为幽默中包含着大量的误导或反讽。
Like, it's not, if you just have a rudimentary understanding of the language, you're not gonna get a lot of humor that's popular in the culture.
就像，如果你对这门语言只有粗浅的理解，你是无法理解很多在该文化中流行的幽默的。
So if you can really understand it comedically, that's why I think it is a really good teacher, because it's like, you know, I would, this would be something for AI, but like, I bet how I met your mother had a larger vocabulary than a lot of other shows all at the time, like sitcoms.
所以，如果你真的能在喜剧层面上理解它，这就是为什么我认为它真是一个很好的老师，因为我觉得，你知道的，虽然这可以说是AI能做的事，但我敢说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》比当时许多其他剧集的词汇量都要大，比如情景喜剧。
Like, you know, not every show's dropping, like making ineffable, like a hilarious plot point, you know, it had a lot of poly-syllabic words.
就像，你知道的，不是每部剧都会抛出像“不可言喻（ineffable）”这样的词，把它变成一个搞笑的剧情点，你知道的，里面有很多多音节词。
Marshall, you know, using legal terms and stuff.
还有马歇尔，你知道的，总是用法律术语之类的。
So I think, I really love what he was saying in this whole thing, but I am, I continue to be delighted.
所以我觉得，我真的很喜欢他在整段话里所表达的，但我依然感到非常高兴。
I have a friend, Nima, who grew up in Tehran until he was 15 and then moved to Canada.
我有个朋友叫尼玛（Nima），他在德黑兰长大到15岁，然后搬到了加拿大。
And he didn't tell me until, I actually met him the same weekend I met my wife, but he is now a very dear friend and he didn't reveal to me until years into our friendship that he learned English from how I met your mother in Scrubs.
直到——其实我认识他的那个周末正是我遇到我妻子的那个周末，但他现在是我非常亲密的朋友，直到我们认识多年后，他才向我透露，他是通过《老爸老妈浪漫史》和《实习医生风云》来学习英语的。
And how I met your mother were the two shows that he just knew backwards and forwards and kind of taught him about America and all this stuff.
而《老爸老妈浪漫史》就是他倒背如流的两部剧之一，它在某种程度上教会了他关于美国的一切以及诸如此类的事情。
So.
所以。
Oh my God, what an honor.
噢天哪，这真是无上的荣誉。
I mean, what an honor that it could be part of someone's journey in learning English and that it continues to mean something.
我是说，能够成为某人英语学习旅程的一部分，并且它能继续保持意义，这是何等的荣誉。
Pardic, thank you so much.
Pardic，非常感谢你。
That was an amazing letter.
那是一封太棒的信了。
Thanks for letting us be part of your story, honestly, it means a lot.
谢谢你让我们成为你故事的一部分，说实话，这意义重大。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thompson.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Madica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马迪卡（Doug Madica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point2Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, AKA Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point2Blue工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格（Emily Blumberg）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）绘制。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》（NYC），由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的Substack邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目重要的组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的缪斯通讯（Muse Letters），在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的长篇处女作小说，你也可以订阅我的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Fathers Society），同样在Substack上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解本节目为筹集先天性心脏病研究资金而进行的持续募捐活动如何能带来改变。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集节目由 Backyard Ventures 倾力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上确实会跳舞。
A real question, it just hit me.
一个真正的问题，刚刚击中了我的心。
Am I in love with you, or just New York City?
我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？